Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. And today we got
a an awesome show because every time
that we have Minnow on, let me pull him
in. Minnow. We know it's going to be a
good show because Minnow's out here
connecting the dots with all kinds of
stuff from politics to the religious
world and how they're uniting and
merging together for the one world
religion that we know prophetically is
soon to come. So, man, I'm like excited
to see what what you got for us tonight,
man.
>> Thank you so much, man. It's good to be
on again. uh and as we as I said last
time um the you know we we spoke about
the history and I think it's good to
connect the dot from the history now to
to what it is today um so we you know a
bad a bad tree cannot bear good fruit
right so uh the fruit that you see right
now uh in in the world today and
especially in the in the evangelical
world is uh what you know that comes out
of the history that we discussed. So I
say it up front uh it's good to see the
history first. So the video that we did
last time uh to understand I mean of
course you can see watch this video but
it's good to see the other video to see
the history where this all comes from
and then uh the players you know that
comes out of it. So like CP Dwagner
we're going to watch that video in a
second. Uh but uh CP Wagner is is the
one you're talking about, right?
>> It's what?
>> This is the video you're talking about.
New apostolic insider,
>> correct? Yes.
>> Yes. Yes. That and that insider was me,
I guess.
>> Yep.
>> Um so, so yeah. So uh that gives a a
little background uh and and I mean on
what's what's you know all these people
that you that I'm going to show on the
screen in a second uh have uh they call
uh CPW their spiritual father uh and
their their their mentor uh if you if
you will um and CPwagner coined the term
uh new apostolic reformation. So you can
roll that uh video right now and then we
go into the and then you can share my
screen.
>> All right, let's check out that first
video.
>> Dominion has to do with control.
Dominion has to do with rulership.
Dominion has to do with authority and
subduing.
My name is Peter Wagner and I'm speaking
to you here from Colorado Springs from
the Wagner Leadership Institute where in
our institute we teach very strongly on
the seven mountains and we teach for
social transformation.
My point is
that we're in the second apostolic age
and and the government of the church
must be in place with apostles and
prophets
which brings us to the dominion mandate.
Now first of all I want to point out
these two words dominion and mandate.
The word mandate, you've got to
understand, mandate means an
authoritative order or command. It
doesn't mean a good idea. It doesn't
mean a suggestion. It means an
authoritative order. Wow. Dominion has
to do with control. Dominion has to do
with rulership. Dominion has to do with
authority and subduing and it relates to
society. Dominion means being the head
and not the tail. Domin dominion means
ruling as kings. It says in Revelation
16 that he has made us kings and
priests. And check the rest of that
verse. It says for dominion. Jesus
delegated establishing his kingdom to
us. What do I mean? To you and to me.
>> We are the ones who are the who are
supposed to bring this about. See Jesus
tra trained his disciples to take charge
after he left. Go ahead and put the
first map up on the screen if you would.
These are just circles. The blue circles
represent apostolic networks. We have
them all over the nation. Now, I'm just
deal with America. They're all over the
world, but we have them all over
America. The black dots represent
individuals.
There is an awesome apostolic grid.
There is an apostolic prophetic grid.
There's an apostolic prophetic
intercession declaration
grid over America. We are positioned now
to do anything he wants to do. And
they're out there. Believe me, they're
everywhere. There are apostles in the
military. There are apostles in
government. There are prophets in
government. There are apostles and
prophets in the media.
>> They are there in entertainment. They
are there in education. You have no idea
what God is about to unleash on this
nation.
>> Wow.
And that was uh quite a while ago,
right? 2016 or so the video set. Um,
>> what what stands out to me is that
they're talking about dominion is not
just a good idea and mandate and all
this stuff that dominion is about
overpowering and and mandate means
forceful. And what does Jesus say? I
stand at the door and knock. It's that
still small voice. He's always drawing
us to him. It's the enemy. It's Satan
that's using uh threats, intimidations,
tricks, psychological, you know,
subliminal.
So, never has religion in God's way has
ever been forceful. It's always like,
if you love me, keep my commandments.
I'm knocking on the door of your heart.
Let me in. He's not bashing indoors and
saying you will worship me or be killed
which is what mandate and dominion mean
to me.
>> Correct. And and also uh you know even
taking dominion of of of
uh I mean take dominion over the earth
and I know the the text that they are
alluding to but that was about fish and
uh you know and uh other things the
dominion over over animals and over
plants and over whatever not over people
right. Um yeah,
>> secondly
>> um uh what uh what's what also stood out
to me um is that um
how do I explain that? Um I lost my
train of thought here. Um yeah, let's go
to my slide. I'll I'll circle back on on
what I wanted to say. Uh so here you see
u uh on on the Wikipedia here uh the and
this list is exhaust is this is just a
small portion of people that are
involved. Uh it's it's bizarre how how
many people are involved in this in this
whole movement. So Chan is one of the
big leaders in in the movement. He's
from California. Uh he has like 25,000
churches under him. Right? As we
discussed last time that's only that's
only him, right? 25,000 churches. Mike
Bickl and we discussed it last time a
little bit. Uh there's a lot of uh
um things happening in in evangelical
world uh like uh you know um sexual
immorality uh of those leaders. This
this guy fell um because he you know for
30 years he he misused uh boys and and
and
that kind of stuff. So, and you will see
that coming back in later on with people
that we also did videos on like Tate as
an example how he was connected.
>> There's it's it's insane. Uh then you
have uh Lauren Bubbert Republican
congressman. Yeah. He said in the
government, in military, well,
>> Michael Flynn as an example in the
military. Lou Angel from the call, but
he is also from the send.
>> Um big organization. Jim Carlo Skyline
Church. I don't know if you if anyone
knows the the the guy um
uh what's his name? Um he took over the
church, Skyline Church from him. He's a
uh like a like a um a motivational
speaker. Um I'll get to his his name in
a minute. Um and then James Go is a big
prophet in in the movement, big apostle,
one of the major ones. Cindy Jacobs is
one of them. Bill Johnson from Bethl
Church, California.
Um, Mike Johnson is involved in it. Uh,
Rick Joiner, uh, he's in Nights of
Malta. We'll see that in a minute as
well in a in an hour in an hour later on
in the presentation.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, John P. Kelly is he's uh, basically
the convening apostle of the Il
International Coalition of Apostolic
Leaders. Uh, I think we closed off with
this this guy last time, Charlie Kirk.
Turning Points USA, he uh mentioned in
the last term with Trump uh he he said
along the lines uh that we we've never
had a president that uh that understood
the seven mountain mandate
in one of in CPAC I believe. So it's
interesting everybody knows the Mike
Lindell the pillow guy.
>> Is he alluding that Trump does
understand the seven mountain mandate?
>> Yes. Yeah. Charlie Kirk said it on a
seatback live. Uh he he he said that. So
I couldn't find the video there. I have
a video of it, but I'll have to show
maybe next time I'll I'll I'll show the
video. Uh Mike Lindell, the pillow guy,
my pillow guy. Uh Galler Maldonado, uh
he's from uh uh from Miami. Uh also uh
you see him with Trump, uh praying for
Trump. Um then I mean the list goes on.
Chuck Pierce. Um Dutch Sheets is the one
that you just saw on the video.
>> Oh yeah.
>> At Svoso, we'll see him as well. He's an
apostle from South America.
Uh and he was involved uh in Was No, it
wasn't him. Somebody else. Um Brian
Simmons, Passion Translation. We'll get
to him uh next. Um so I mean Roger Stone
as an example here uh this guy is from a
European apostolic leader. So he he
oversees the European the ICEL is for
for international US is for the US and
then this one is for Europe. So the EAL
uh CP Wagner coined the term new
apostolic reformation. And there are
people that are saying like a new
apostolic reformation doesn't exist.
Well we just heard C. Peter Wagner tell
everybody that it does exist, right? So
>> Lance Wallnau, the guy that basically uh
uh he had the two guys that I explained
last time uh Cunningham and and Bright
those were the those had the vision of
the seven mountains and Lance Walnut put
it in a book the seven mountain mandate
uh together with Bill Johnson Paula
White next to Trump right so she's now
the official
>> uh uh faith office in in uh in um uh
here in the US, right? So interesting.
Then you have Todd White, of course. Um
so and this is just uh one of many. So
so that's the list here. Um now we here
you have the seven mountain mandate and
it's interesting if you look at the
dominionism, right? If you look at the
the seven mountains, family, religion,
education, media, entertainment,
business, and government. You can tweak
here and there a little bit of the
words, but um this is going to be very
very scary if you if we go to uh losses
trust here
uh from Alice Bailey, right? The new age
uh
>> movement. Uh it's about the the the the
Christ, right? The reappearing of the
Christ. Wherever and this is new age.
This is not Christianity. Just for
clarification,
>> right? Wherever these objectives can
best be nurtured, the Christ will work.
Obviously, therefore, he could emerge as
a vital force in any field in education,
>> in government and government is
legislation, judicial and executive,
right? So, that is that is the second
one. Yeah.
>> Uh education, government,
>> science, business, economics, social
affairs and religion.
>> And religion. How many? Wow. Seven.
Seven.
>> Yeah,
>> I want to make a point, too.
>> I want to make a point for anybody
that's maybe new to studying the Bible
or haven't been big into prophecy or
anything like that because I know some
people are just like afraid to read
Revelation, but the book of Revelation
when it describes the harlot, the we are
the pure bride of Christ and then
there's this harlot. These are symbolic.
It's all symbolic language in
Revelation. Um, and when John's eyes are
fixated, he's the one that wrote
Revelation. When his eyes are fixated on
this harlot who's sitting on a beast
drinking blood and all this stuff,
that's all describing Rome, the Roman
Empire that will uh become
strong again. You know, it's it's every
every world leader goes over and flies
over and meets the pope, every
president, every, you know, Hitler,
everybody. So, they've never really lost
power. or at some point they they
suffered a fatal head wound, but then it
says that that fatal head wound would
heal. And I think that that's already
happening. But in Revelation 17:9, it
says, "And here is the mind which hath
wisdom, the seven heads of this beast
are seven mountains on which the woman
siteth." And so if you understand that a
woman represents a church, a harlot
would represent a corrupt church. She's
sitting on a beast which represents a
nation. And that nation has seven heads
which are seven hills or seven
mountains. And you can Google this
stuff. What is a city of seven hills?
Boom. It's going to tell you Rome. And
it's just interesting that there's So
I'll just type that in. What is the city
of seven hills? And there you see it.
Um, Rome. So what is the corrupt and
then then funny enough the US too,
right? So but
>> so what is the corrupt church that sits
in Rome? Obviously it's Vatican. Um,
it's also dressed in purple and scarlet
and all that stuff. So when you have
this talking about seven mountains, it's
like boom, that's Rome Vatican or
Vatican Rome mandate. Now you're putting
the word mandate in there. It's like
it's almost prophetically saying forcing
all the world to return back to Rome.
All roads point to Rome, right?
>> Yeah. Well, uh, funny enough, the US of
course as we mentioned is is a uh the
image of the beast, right? So, uh you
see that in in the capital in the US
that's also on seven hills. Uh and then
uh funny enough is that this is uh uh
the uh evangelical the the the
um Protestant movement basically
pointing back to Rome.
>> Yeah.
>> It's very ecumenical and they they all
want want to go back to Rome. So yeah,
it's it's fascinating that that
everything is is just coming to life
right now.
>> It really is, man. prophecy happening
right before our very eyes.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. So, uh if
you if you if you want um so uh if you
want a false revival, right, that's what
they're all all going for, right? Then
you also need to to rewrite the Bible.
And this guy here is and we saw him, I
just mentioned him, Brian Simmons. He is
basically the the sole translator of uh
the the passion translation and in air
quotes translation because um
>> it's not really a translation.
>> Um and this guy uh he is uh I mean he is
the translator of the passion
translation. He also is professor
also between air quotes professor
>> unacredited
>> uh professor at Vagner University. Uh,
and that is of course Wagner stands for
uh, Peter Wagner. We saw him just on the
video. Um, and also
close to Cindy Jacobs and he is also
part of the ACPE which is the Apostolic
Council of Prophetic Elders.
Um, so yeah, it's interesting. Uh, and
if you if you and here you see like the
the the Wagner University and you see
all the instructors and you see all the
same people again. See, Peter Wagner, he
passed away. Then you have Jay, which we
delve in later. Uh Cindy Jacobs,
uh that was all on the list. You saw him
on the list. Uh this one that you didn't
see on the list, but he is under Chan.
Chris Felatin's from Battle Church,
California under Bill Johnson. Brian
Simmons. Again,
>> can I interject something about this
Passion translation?
>> Yeah.
Um, this guy, just for anybody who
doesn't know, because I I wouldn't have
known this except we did a show on
Little Light Studios about this.
Somebody, a guest came on that really
investigated this. And uh, it says right
here, according to Simmons, Jesus
personally commissioned him to translate
the Bible in 2009, breathing on him and
giving him a spirit of revelation. He
describes the translation process as an
intense and charismatic experience
involving divine downloads, supernatural
insights, and even visitations.
He claims Jesus promised him secrets of
the Hebrew language, and that he
received revelation about how to
translate certain verses like Ephesians
5:22 according to Holly Pivik. I mean,
this is crazy when you have somebody
who's openly saying, "Um, yeah, I had a
face tof face encounter with Jesus and
he told me exactly how to translate the
Bible." Was was God's word not preserved
through the dark ages and everything
already. This is making me think of, you
know, when pe when Paul says, "If anyone
comes preaching another gospel
because we don't need another
translation of the Bible,
I I just
>> I it's a red flag to me if you're having
some kind of spiritual encounter and
someone and this spirit is saying you
need to rewrite the Bible."
>> Well, it's it's getting worse even. Uh
here is Patricia King. She's also uh
very famous. Uh Bill Johnson here. And
then Doris Wagner is uh his wife who is
still uh uh overseeing everything. Uh
and then I don't know these people. Um
so and then here Lance Wall again you
saw him on the on the list
>> Rebecca Greenwood.
>> So yeah, it's uh it's very interesting.
Uh then let's go to uh the first of the
second video. Okay. Um Brian Brian
Simmons and that's kind of explaining
what you just mentioned in
>> Oh, about the passion.
>> About the passion translation.
>> Oh, interesting. Okay.
>> Yeah.
Oh, I don't hear anything.
>> Yeah, I don't either. Um let's see. Why
do we not have sound?
>> Hello.
Welcome to my world where it's naturally
supernatural.
My guest found himself in the library of
heaven
>> and he saw books on every subject you
can imagine.
Books on science and medicine, things
like cancer cures that haven't even
occurred yet.
And then he saw one book that was called
John
22.
There only 21 books in the Gospel of
John.
22 had to do about the next great
greatest revival the world has ever
seen. I want you to get some insight.
I'll be right back.
[Music]
Okay. How in the world did you get into
the library room of heaven? I want to go
there. Well, you know, as believers in
Christ, there's only one entrance into
the realm of the spirit, and that is the
name of Yeshua, the name of Jesus
Christ. It's we don't work it up. We
don't get into an ecstatic state on our
own. I was actually asleep and I was
taken out of my body and I was brought
into this immense library room. I loved
being there and the Lord came up to me
and he said, "Brian, I have brought you
here
>> to let you take any two books you want."
And and I'm just walking around, but it
didn't take long before I saw a book
that I knew I was to have. And then soon
I saw another book I knew I was to have.
But uh you'll never want me back on the
show when I tell you what happened then.
>> What?
>> Well, I have to tell you the truth. I
saw a third book and I knew the Lord
told me I could only take two. And in
heaven, whatever you think is put out
over the loudspeaker. Everyone hears it.
Your thoughts are broadcasted. So here's
what I hear coming out of the
loudspeaker, and it's my own thoughts.
How can I steal this book?
And then I said, "Oh no, I'm shoplifting
on God." I I felt so ashamed that I but
I knew if I could take this book, there
was this book. So if I could just take
this book back with me to the natural
realm, it would trigger awakening in all
the nations of the earth. It would bring
the it would make the name of Jesus
famous on the in the world. But Jesus
came to me and said, "Brian, I cannot
let you take this book. I can't wait.
>> And he looked at me in the eyes with
love that melted me and he said, "You
are not ready
>> for that book."
>> Then he promised,
>> "But I will bring you back one day
>> and I will give you
>> and I will give you that book."
>> What was the title?
>> Written on the cover of the book was
John 22.
>> But there's only 21 chapters in John.
What's this 22?
>> Well, John 22.
Go back to John 14:12 and you'll see
that there is a greater works
generation. The works that I do, you
will do even greater works than these. I
believe the John 22 generation will be a
people that do the greater works of
Jesus. They will not add to the
scripture and and that's a sealed book.
But it is a book that is unfolding and
the works of Jesus will be replicated by
an entire generation of people that
believe fully in the power of God.
>> Oh man.
>> It's not adding to the book, but uh it's
an extra book, right? Like
>> Oh yeah.
>> What? So such double speak, man. It's
and the greatest revival, right? The
greatest revival. And it's coming, a
revival, a false revival. That's for
sure.
>> The sad part is this guy could be 100%
um genuine. You know, he might really
have had this experience and really
believe that it's a good thing and I saw
Jesus and it's great revival's coming.
But we don't see that in the Bible. The
Bible doesn't mention anything about
that the world's going to there's going
to be a great revival before Jesus comes
back. It actually says the complete
opposite. There's going to be a falling
away first. Um but we know that there's
going to be a false revival. We know
there's going to be a false spirit. Uh
there's going to be lying signs and
wonders, miracle working demons that are
going to deceive
like almost everybody. It says only the
very elect, if it were possible, even
they would be deceived.
And and so what is all this deception? A
lot of people think that like the Left
Behind movies, like there's this one man
that just hates Christians. He's killing
them in the streets. But that's not
deceptive. There's nothing deceptive
about killing Christians in the streets.
Deception is bringing about a false love
movement. It's all about love. You know,
if we just love each other and accept
each other and be tolerant, we have
perfect peace on earth and we're all all
roads lead to God. No matter if you're a
Buddhist or Muslim or newager, it's all
just a different way to God. It's all
it's all love that we worship.
>> Yep. Yep.
>> That's deception coming.
>> Yeah. Oh, absolutely. There's a there's
a The next video is even worse. And
that's not the video. Next video.
>> So this one is uh so uh Chris Rose is a
friend of mine. He uh he did a critique
on the video. So you'll hear him too.
But uh what Brian Simmons is saying
here. Remember in the last video we
talked about that uh you know the little
gods theology.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh this is this is nothing different.
And you can roll the video.
>> All right.
A bad tree can't bear good fruit. The
passion translation is the fruit of this
guy's and he's the tree. Let's just put
it that way. It ain't good fruit. And
listen to this.
>> He's within us.
The Revelation 12 virgin bride will give
birth to a manchild company, a corporate
expression. One has become many. The
seed has now fallen in the ground and
died, but is now bearing many seeds.
There's a many seeded Christ. He will
prolong his day. There there's a many
seated Christ coming.
>> Yeah. What does that mean?
>> And take pleasure in what he sees.
Isaiah 53 says that that he will see his
seed
>> and prolong his days. We are extending
the ministry of Jesus throughout the
nations. We are carrying his life and
his nature and his DNA wherever we go.
We are we're carrying his DNA.
>> Huh?
We're to preach the gospel. Proclaim
Christ and him crucified for our sins.
What are you talking about?
>> Yeah.
>> Prolonging his days. The Acts 29
company. We are expressing the Christ
wherever we go. And as the corporate
maturity uh continues and we rise to be
the holy temple unto the Lord, there
will be that under the apple tree
conception.
>> What does that mean?
Something's going to get conceived under
the apple tree. Will there be fornal
kabutilating happening underneath the
apple tree? What are you talking about?
>> And the Christ we long for
will be seen in a corporate way.
>> Christ will be seen in a corporate way.
Huh?
There's a coming glory.
>> If you look at Antichrist, the devil,
you look at judgment, you know, bowls,
trumpets, and uh let's see, seals,
trumpets, and bowls, all three of those.
I don't know how far to go with you
guys.
>> Yeah. Weird. I mean, if you were just
exeding, you could just exedute the
passage. But see, he's revealing
something new.
>> Something they've never heard before.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Yeah. All
>> three of them refer to people. You're
sealed with the Holy Spirit. I could
show you the seven seals from the New
Testament. Seven times it says you're
sealed.
>> Uh so we're the seals that are broken
on the scroll in the book of Revelation.
Really? No.
>> Wow.
>> Sealed book is you. He's the word, the
volume of the book. It is written of
him. We express the word. We are the
word made flesh again. We are the
>> Oh, dude.
>> Oh, man. We're the word made flesh
again.
>> So, we're Christ.
>> So, you and I, the the body of Christ,
we are an in we are the in we are the
the reincarnation
>> of Christ.
>> Reincarnation of Jesus Christ. Oh, he
>> Yeah, that's what I thought. I'm going
to back this up so you can hear it in
context. So listen again.
>> Book is you. He's the word. The volume
of the book. It is written of him. We
express the word. We are the word made
flesh again. We are the reincarnation of
Jesus Christ. Wow. Wow.
Yeah. So you and I are the reincarnation
of Jesus Christ. No, we're not.
>> Wow man.
>> Oh my goodness. this. I mean, seriously,
Jesus Christ is God in human flesh. We
are not.
>> Wow, man.
>> That is
again, we're gods, right? We're godhood.
That's the new age. So, so you see,
yeah, it's straight up new age.
>> And that's the guy that wrote the
passion translation and that's one of
the higher apostles in the movement,
right? So,
I mean,
we're done, right? Let's
>> got he's got his own Bible.
>> Yeah, he created his own Bible and it's
it's it's crazy. Uh so, no wonder that
uh you know that that the whole movement
is is
sinking sand basically. Uh yeah, I mean,
what else can you ask? It's an appealing
doctrine because it's like
it sounds so inclusive and you know
there's no judgment and there's no
repent no repentance. I mean if we are
the reincarnation of Christ we don't
need to repent. I mean we're sinless
and so we're all we're all divine. We're
all definitely heaven bound
and really yeah like I said there's no
judgment or anything.
all your heathen friends out there,
they're all on their journey, too. And
one day we'll all get there.
>> Yep.
>> Wow, man.
>> So, and then uh the next video uh that
is um uh kind of the fruit of of the
whole new epic reformation as well,
right? So, we we talked about like um
um
uh
uh in the beginning I said like all the
the
misconduct, the the
how you call it the sexual uh
>> oh yeah
>> sins uh and this is this is the highest
apostle again that uh not this guy this
guy is exposing it but uh yeah take a
listen and we'll we'll comment
afterwards. all right
>> about uh his translation. So, here
here's a clip uh from uh from a recent
uh sermon Brian Simmons was uh preaching
and I've got some other clips here from
some other folks. I'll list all the uh
links in the u in the about section. So
13 years ago, I had a very supernatural
experience where the Lord made it clear
that his plan for the rest of my life or
at least a portion of it was to
translate the Bible. I mean that's
crazy. Who does that?
>> Um scholars, Brian, uh we call them
scholars. You see uh to translate the
text of the scriptures you have to go
back to the original texts which are in
other languages. And so to be qualified
to do that you must understand those
other languages must be quite proficient
in those um other languages. That's why
we you know we want scholars to
translate those texts into our own
language. But Brian Simmons is not a
scholar by his own admission. Brian
Simmons, who did this translation, is
not qualified for the task. He only has
a degree in prayer from Wagner
University. Take note that this is an
unacredited university started by the
head of the New Apostolic Reformation
himself, Peter C. Wagner.
Ah, see Peter Wagner's University where
you learn that Christians are to conform
to the culture of the world and also
that Christians ought to like women's
cleavage.
>> I I put Sunho here. See, but because she
gets all the support in the world from
her husband and her church to do what?
To move up and up and up in the Arts and
Entertainment Mountain.
You've got to understand that every one
of these seven mountains has a different
culture.
>> The religion mountain has one culture.
Every one of the other six has a
different culture.
So if you're going to arise in influence
in any of the mountains, you've got to
obey in the rule book of that culture.
And this is this is one of the
illustration in that talk of sonho. I
mean I love her. What? What? Now, now
here's where it gets interesting. What
happened was that that someone took uh I
mean, one of those many pictures that
was taken showed up on the cover of one
of these magazines, you know what I
mean? And it was circulated back in
Singapore.
And the pastors in Singapore had an
uproar about Sunho.
And their problem was on this magazine
cover there was too much cleavage.
So these pastors disliked cleavage so
much
that they they actually had a meeting
and condemned Sunho. And I took a hit
too because I used to have a Wagner
Leadership Institute in Singapore and my
Wagner Leadership Institute director was
part of that meeting that they had. And
when they found out that I was one of
the cheerleaders of Sunho, they closed
down Wagner Leadership Institute.
I don't care. I'm still cheerleading for
Sunho.
>> Wow.
[Music]
>> You got that picture up there? There's
Son Ho
in the religion mountain.
See how she's dressed? What does she
look like? Pastor's wife, the co-pastor,
right? Perfect for the religion. Here's
Sunho in the arts and entertainment
mound. Woohoo.
Sister Helen.
There's only one way to cook Colonel
Sanders Kentucky Fried Chicken, and
that's my way. We always use plump young
broilers, always fresh, never frozen
chicken. It's cut in pieces and each
piece is dipped in milk and egg wash.
Then into seasoned flour in which we
have the 11 different spices and herbs
for flavor,
[Laughter]
but they those pers
so disturbed.
So that's what you learn at uh Wagner
Institute of of Leadership that uh you
should conform to the patterns of the
world and also not be upset about
>> Wow,
man.
>> So there you go your answer.
>> We bring the world bring the world back
into into the church, right?
>> That's
>> Yeah. We're supposed to be not conformed
to this world. We're supposed to be set
apart. We're supposed to be new
creatures in Christ. When we become a
Christian, we walk like him. We walk
like Christ and we have a renewed mind
and and we're we're not even the same
person anymore. That old man is dead.
You don't even recognize the old person
anymore. I mean, you can look at old
pictures of me and I don't even
recognize myself anymore.
And uh that's something that I see often
in the church
is that we're we're trying so hard to
reach the world that we're becoming the
world to try and reach them. But are we
really reaching them when you have, you
know, Fortnite day at the youth group,
you know, come on guys, come to the
youth group. We're going to kill each
other. We're going to shoot each other
all day. How is that actually drawing
people to Christ? You know, maybe
there's a little nugget at the end, you
know. Well, we're glad you guys all
came. I want to read a Bible verse, John
3:16, and hope you accept Christ. And
didn't you have a lot of fun here today
doing what what the world does? You
know, there's nothing different. Why
would why would somebody choose to join
what you're involved in when it's no
different than the world?
>> I I agree.
Yeah. So, and he's I mean he's the head
of the whole New Apostolic Reformation.
>> Wow.
So, yeah, it's crazy. So, if we go to
the to my screen,
>> okay,
>> here you see uh one of the other
leaders, Cindy Jacobs. You saw her um
she was also teaching at the Wagner
Institute, right? So,
>> I mean, they're all all part of the same
the same the same group. So here you see
generals international
that's her own organization. Here you
see a reformation prayer network. Uh she
has a whole organization in every state
basically a whole prayer prayer network.
It's massive. Um I mean she's part of
empower 21. I will get back to that one
in later.
Um, but here you see people that she's,
uh, she's, uh, you know, working with.
Uh, here you see Harry Jackson.
Uh, some people you might recognize.
Uh, here you see James Go. We get to him
in a moment. So, they all hang out
together, right? So, it's all uh, but
yeah, here there's Dutch Sheets or uh,
yeah, Dutch Sheets. It's the guy the guy
with the all the all the dots on the
screen, remember?
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. Uh here's uh James Go
again. And that guy James Go, he was uh
the the last uh any archers that we went
to, he was the the the pass for the
overseeing the pastors over there.
>> Wow.
>> So I've se seen what what damage that
can can be done. Right. So here you see
Lou Angle. It's also on the list.
>> Um yeah, it's um this is the AC uh ACP.
So this is Doris Wagner, CP Peter
Wagner's wife. Uh this is James
Cooligan. And they're founding members,
right? So these are leaders and founding
members of the ACP, the Council for
Prophetic Elders, the Apostolic Council
of Prophetic Elders.
>> So Jenniferlair, she's also very much
into the the um
demon slayer kind of camp. Um,
and here you see Bill Johnson. And here
you see um, uh, Maldonado again and and
and Cindy Jacobs, of course. So, yeah,
it's um, it's interesting. Uh, um, here
you see Sean Voit. Sean Voit.
>> Who is that guy? I recognize him.
>> This guy or this guy?
>> Yeah, Sean right there.
>> Yeah, Sean. He he was from B he he was
with Battle and he was the guy that was
doing he was the guy who was doing the
uh the he was the guy that was doing the
tour throughout the the nation when co
was going on right those revivals.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
And he he is also on a picture with uh
Jonathan Roomie and Roomie stated has
this picture of him and Jonathan Roomie
and he said that he met his fellow
Templars.
>> So I I assume
>> I assume so. I I don't have evidence,
but if he's saying that with Shawn Voit
on the picture, his fellow Templars, I'm
like, well,
>> I think that's why I recognize him
because I I do remember that post.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was a little light.
I had a a few of those uh uh chosen
videos and uh I told uh I told her um uh
one of the
was it um
>> Dick?
>> I'm blanking. Denique. Yeah, I told
Benique uh that's uh the you know zoom
in on the video on on that photo because
he's part of the Templars uh if he's
saying that's that that you know with
him on the picture.
>> Anyway, this is Michael's lens now. So
all the connections, right? This these
are screenshots from their own
Instagram, right? So I mean Cindy
Jacobs, right? Their own posts. Benny
Hinn remarry his own wife,
>> Reinard Bonkey. So, all these big
evangelists, here's Heidi Baker. Uh,
they're all part of the same club.
Here's Rick Joiner, Nights of Malta,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, uh, here's Christine Kaine from
Hillsong. So, it's all connected. It's
all connected.
>> Yeah.
>> Here's Patricia King. Here's, uh, this
this lady here. Um, what's her name? Uh,
oh, here. Have you ever heard of Amy
Simple McFersonson and the Angalist
Temple? That's the four square
denomination.
>> Okay. I've heard square.
>> Yeah. Well, that is uh basically uh Amy
Sample McFersonson was was kind of the
the the head of that church, but that's
also part of the N. Uh here you see Bill
Haymon.
Uh he also believes that uh that man can
become God and uh the the
in the last days the new breed basically
the superpower super superman right that
that have the ability to to do miracles
and wow
>> yeah here you see a whole bunch of them
so anyway so just here you see Sidroat
right they're all in the same club and
and you and I are not in it
>> yeah and these are you So when you ask
>> mandate that's the generals
international her own organization.
This is this is Cindy Jacobs website.
Here's Cindy Jacobs. Uh and here you see
the seven mountain mandate, right?
>> Yeah.
That's crazy, dude. Yeah. When you ask
like the secular world, like what do you
think of when you think of Christianity?
It's these people. I mean, these are the
ones that have the biggest platforms.
They got the biggest stage. they're on
TV,
you're not seeing, you know, Jesus said
the way to life is narrow and few will
be to find it. That men are going to
hate you for my name's sake. That the
things that they hated him. They said
there they hate you, but they remember
they hated me first. And why' they hate
him? Because of truth. He came to the
Pharisees and said, "You guys are
hypocrites."
And then nailed him to a cross for it.
Yep. I know. Yeah.
>> So, when you're teaching truth, you
know, you're not going to have a big
audience. You're not going to have a big
following. And that just shows that is
the fruit of this. When you see that
these things are growing, mega churches,
millions of dollars, helicopters,
private jets, all that stuff.
>> That's already a red flag.
>> Roller coasters and big bouncing houses,
whatever. It's I don't know what what
other kind of props they have these
days, but
>> yeah,
>> it's already a red flag that this is not
in line with truth.
>> No, it it tickles the ears. Uh and for
everyone there's something, right? So
there's a seeker driven and then you
have your your your power evangelists,
your your signs and wonders church and
for everyone there's something.
>> So here I'm going to the next slide
here. the P. We're still in the Passion
translation. Here you see the official
website here. Passion translation
>> endorsements.
You see Bill Johnson.
>> Wow. Yeah.
>> He's reading from the Passion
translation.
>> Who is this? Bobby Houston from
Hillsong, right? Well, they had an
issue, of course, but Hillsong is using
it.
>> Uh, and then I don't know that David
HSholder. Then you have Lou Angel, the
one from the call and from uh the call
and descent big uh big stadium event
right that he that he's doing. Uh then
you have James Go here the other apostle
that is under Chayan
uh and he was his mentor was uh uh C.
Peter Wagner and uh James go again this
is the guy that that was uh you know
overseeing the the pastors that the
church that we went to. Wow.
>> Here you see John Elisa Bevere. I don't
know if you know these guys. Uh John was
uh basically um under Benny Hinn. He was
his personal assistant.
>> This is amazing. So this Bible that was
uh you know
rewritten is being pushed by some of the
biggest names in quote unquote
Christianity.
>> Yep. Patricia King. She's all about
portals and and kind of stuff. You see
Heidi Baker see all the same names,
right? All the same names.
>> She's also Wagner Institute. Uh he's
Wagner Institute, right? So there's a
lot of overlap here and there. Heidi
Baker is also connected to Bethl. Uh
Benning Leapure Jesus culture
>> is also part was part of Bethl came out
of Bethl. He is all are endorsing this
here. You see Chayan the guy that we
that we're gonna dive in later.
Um, here's again Campbell, Stacy and
Wesley Campbell, also part of of the of
a group with Heidi Baker and Bill
Johnson and Chan. Graham Cook is another
uh prophet in the movement. Chuck Pierce
uh one of those uh guys as well in and
he is really cookie. I
>> mean, he's he says the weirdest stuff.
Uh Andy Andrew
uh she is a co-pastor pastor Jake
Hamilton a worship leader I don't know
him but
uh Dan Wilson Cal Pierce
Lana Foster and uh this one Bianca you
Huarez Olto she is working with uh again
with Hillsong Christine Kaine um very
closely so
>> Bible teacher which Bible is she
teaching from. Wow.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Ste Steve
wasn't. So, yeah. Um and then you see
here John and Lisa Beir like right John
Beir. We just saw his endorsement,
right?
>> Yep.
>> He was a youth pastor and then as Hinn's
personal assistant.
>> So,
>> man, that's just how Satan works, man.
Like, you know, the Bible says, "Train
up a child on the way they should go."
Satan knows that. Hitler knew that.
There's all kinds of, you know, you hear
that quote like, uh, give me the youth
and I'll control the future. And that
it's
>> they say Hitler said it, but some
there's some dispute about it, but it's
true. The the youth is the future. If
you can I mean, like our kids, they're
growing up in a world where, oh, there's
86 genders and you can kind of flow in
and out and yeah, men marry men and all
that kind of stuff. That's normal
because
you know gay marriage was legalized 10
years ago or something. Now kids growing
up this is their normal life. Every
generation that something becomes
normalized they don't know any
different. And so if you want if you
were Satan and you wanted to corrupt the
church which is his whole mission like
he doesn't have to corrupt the world.
They're already lost. They're already in
the bars fornicating spending all their
time on games and all that stuff. He
doesn't have to attack them. His main
focus of attack is in the church and he
has to infiltrate through Jesuits,
through Freemasons, all this stuff. And
if he can change the Bible and get the
biggest people in the Christian world to
promote that Bible and to read from that
Bible and do sermons on that Bible and
and then this guy, a youth pastor,
get him to share this Bible with the
youth. I mean, this is all they're gonna
know.
>> Oh, this is getting word. Yeah, this is
sharing. But I'll you'll see in a second
what what else he did.
>> But this is this is Matt Hegy. Uh he his
father is John Hegy.
>> John and he Yeah. And he says that uh
that Jews don't have to uh uh come to
Christ. They're already saved, right?
>> Yep. They're they're promised in. Man,
that that's the
>> that's the craziest thing to me because
>> the Jews literally reject Christ. Do we
believe the Bible when it says there's
no way to the father but by me. I am the
way, the truth, the life. I mean, why do
where did this idea that these, you
know, the whole parable of the rich man
and Lazarus, which people love to use
that to prove that there is an eternal
torment in hell, that wasn't even the
point of the parable. The parable was
that your bloodline and your wealth will
not save you. Because that was the
belief at the time. I'm a Jew. I'm
wealthy. I must be blessed by God. And
Jesus came and flipped that whole thing
and said, "No, it was actually the lowly
beggar that made it, not not the rich
Jew,
>> man."
>> Yeah. So Matt Hegy also adopted the
seven mountain mandate. So it's uh uh
then you have here um Ben Fitzgerald. is
a Bethl uh BSSM student and he was one
of the ones that did the the grave
soaking.
>> Oh.
>> And on the right on the right side here
uh this is the daughter of Benny Hinn.
Uh and uh let's see here.
I mean uh Joanie Lamb from uh um what's
the TV station? Dayar.
>> Oh yeah. Um, I mean, Robert Morris,
another guy that fell down recently
because he 20 years ago for five years
he abused a a little girl. Uh, he's
standing in trial. I think in this year
or next year
um I had to step down. He's from Gateway
Church and I think the first IAL meeting
the international coalition of apostolic
leaders uh was done at his church and
later you will see also that he's
mentioned by Chayan uh in in one of the
videos that he uh that he is also an
apostle.
>> Um anyway uh you see this is these are
the the pastors of the church that I I
went to in Nashville at the belonging
>> and they're very close friends of
course.
Uh here you see also that he's promoting
Chris Fatin's book from from Bethl.
Right. So it's all connected and you
tick on my if I you you scratch my back,
I scratch yours. Right. Right.
>> That's how it works. And this is the guy
again,
>> Ben Fitzgerald. Uh Bethl uh Jen Johnson,
Brian Johnson, son of Bill Johnson, and
she is uh of course the worship. They're
from the worship band.
Uh and the here at Hillsong,
I mean here at Sid Roth, we just saw it
with with Brian Simmons. Uh but the
shocking thing Oh, Chris Hodes at uh the
Ark Churches is another movement. I'll
get into that as well. Here you see him
promoting uh Louis Gigglio from um the
Passion Conference in Atlanta.
>> Um so it's it's bizarre. museum with the
striper guys.
>> Wow.
>> Music industry. Christine Kane, right?
Uh from Hillsong. I'm trying to get Joel
Ostein. We just saw in a video before,
right? That Joel Ostein.
>> Yeah.
>> When I was mentioning Mega Churches and
all that, I always picture his face, but
I didn't want to just throw his name
under the bus without proof. But there
it is. There's the connection there.
>> Yeah. Jensen Franklin, who was also with
Trump all the time, right? on on the on
the Trump train. Here is another false
prophet. He's called the Google prophet.
He looks on Google and and uh Facebook
and and checks uh information and then
he's doing his prophecy.
>> Oh wow.
>> Here's here's John HGY as mentioned
before.
>> So it's And here you see something very
interesting. What is that?
>> Passion translation. What does it say?
John Bafir states, "Lisa and I are so
excited to be part of this project and
endorse what has become one of our
favorite translation of the
>> byway." Wow.
>> They have been a part of this project.
>> They That's what I was saying. This it's
not only they they endorse it, they were
part of this whole journey.
>> And you saw with all the people that
they're hanging out with and endorsing,
right? And who is endorsing them?
>> So, When I when I've been gathering all
that data and information, connecting
the dots, people don't realize that that
that's the case. It's it's bizarre.
>> So Heidi Baker, another person here
endorsing the the Passion translation,
right? And she is hanging out with
whoever uh Leaf Hetland from
I think it's uh Leaf Hetland from
Scandinavia, Randy Clark. He was the one
that brought the the so-called Toronto
blessing to Toronto,
>> which is the condolini spirit. That's uh
in the 90s and stuff when you saw all
the people that were twitching with Kas
and barking like dogs and speaking
gibberish and drunk in the spirit and
all that stuff.
>> He was blessed by by uh the the Holy
Ghost laughter guy uh Holy Ghost
bartender
um Rodney Howard Brown.
>> Rodney Howard Brown. Uh and and and also
uh Fright Zone. Um that's an a Latin
American guy.
>> I grew up on those like VHS's and stuff.
We we went to a charismatic
non-denominational church. And uh
actually the church we went to, Kenneth
Copelan would sometimes visit just to
sit in the crowd. And um yeah, we were
all into that back then, the Rodney
Howard Brown. And we we believed it,
man. We thought,
>> look at that. This is the the move of
the Holy Ghost.
>> Yeah. So, uh here Life Hadland and Heidi
Baker. Here's uh um Life Headland again.
Who is this guy? Um let's see here. What
else do we have? Here's the This is the
Toronto guy from Toronto, the the
church, John and Carol Arnut. They've
met with the Pope
>> uh with Kenneth Copeland. Uh so there's
the Kenneth Copeland connection again.
Bill Johnson spoke at the Kenneth
Copelan conference several times. Uh
this is here's your Jay on again. We get
into him uh in a minute. Um Heidi Baker
again. So this this is the uh um the And
then these guys Bonov these guys are all
part of how do you call it the
the alliance. What is it? The
something with the alliance. But we'll
get to that uh in a moment.
Let's see here. This is a guy from from
from uh Europe. He's very famous in
Europe
>> bringing that uh whole thing in Europe.
Let's see where is that other video.
Um yeah, here's Todd White, right? So,
it's everybody together. Kumbaya.
>> Todd White is the first time I ever
heard of Bill. What was the guy's name?
Bill Johnson.
>> Bill Johnson. Yeah. Todd White kept
talking about how Bill Johnson trained
him, was his mentor and all.
>> This is the guy here. This is Cladio
Frightzone. He was the one that uh that
uh that uh basically brought uh together
with Rodney Howard Brown here. Those two
brought basically uh the the blessing to
Randy Clark and Randy Clark brought it
to AR John Arnold
>> and Heidi Baker
>> fire.
>> Yeah. And he brought it to Heidi Baker.
So it's all connected, man. And then you
have here Michael Michael Brown, right?
He's
>> he he doesn't believe that the NAR
exists, right?
>> And he's a part of it.
>> Yeah. They're all kumbaya all together.
It's uh Anyway,
so they're all part and this is the
son-in-law of Beni Hin. So they're all
part of it, man. It's all the same. All
the same.
>> Anyway, I can't find the other one that
I was looking for, but uh it's the it's
an they call it an alliance. This guy's
from the Netherlands. Very famous. Mate
is from the Spain. He moved to Miami.
Anyway, oh here is it these ones? No.
Anyway, forget it. Then here's
another I'll go to the next one.
Otherwise, we never
>> You did um you did briefly say something
that I wanted to share with people if
they've never heard this before. You
said that Bethl, they were the ones that
were involved in grave soaking. If
you've never heard of this, these people
part of Bethl church, they will go out
to graveyards
and lay on the tombstones of, you know,
famous preachers or whatever people that
they considered prophets
and they'll hug the tombstones and lay
on the tombstones and they call it grave
soaking. They're trying to receive the
blessing
supposedly um from these people's
graves. This is necromancy all the way.
Like the dead are dead. The dead know
nothing. They're rotting in that grave
until Christ returns.
And
what Christian thought that this was a
good idea to go out and hug tombstones
and lay on them and and try and receive
the blessing from the dead corpse of
this person. See Bethl Church that is
his wife Bill Johnson's wife.
>> Wow, dude.
>> Yeah. This is this is demented stuff
right here. Satanic.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, this is Bill Johnson.
That's uh the w the wife of Bill
Johnson, late wife. She passed away. And
they're all about healing. And everybody
should be healed. That's what they say,
right? But his wife died because of
cancer. So
>> it's it's interesting, right?
>> That is interesting.
>> Never ne never trust a healer with
glasses.
>> Yeah. Right. That's true. Why is he Oh,
wow. Good point.
>> Yeah.
>> Why are you wearing glasses if you can
be healed?
>> Uh Revival Alliance was the organization
I was alluding to.
>> But here you see him with uh with the
praying prophet. Uh here you see him
with again with the guy from from Europe
and uh
they're all everything is connected
here. You see Brian Johnson, Bill
Johnson's son with John Franklin.
>> You see him with uh again with Ben
Fitzgerald also the grave guy.
>> Wow.
>> He hated again that you saw with Heidi
Baker. Uh you see him with Benny Hinn
and Randy Clark again. Also, he got the
false fire from uh from Toronto, by the
way.
>> Wow.
>> So, it's everything is connected. It's
crazy. Here's Chuck Pierce and the other
guy uh the the again from the Wagner
University, right?
Connected with very close with dot
sheets, the guy with the dots on the
screen.
Uh I'm going quickly through that one.
So this one here,
>> Natalie Grant, she is a a song uh she's
a a famous artist in the CCM and she's
also grant right
>> I don't know.
>> I think she is.
>> Um what I do know is that she is um uh
at the belongings she's a worship leader
and um uh this is what she's selling.
>> What is that? Passion translation.
>> If you read it here, it says
>> she she basically uh had um here. Okay.
So, I know there are so many
advertisements and everyone is having a
sale, but I wanted to let you know about
a couple of things that I think are
really special gifts. Of course, we have
limited quantities, but swipe through
and then head on over to blah blah blah.
Uh, the 2020 No Stranger Special Edition
Passion Translation Bible.
>> Oh man,
>> I love this powerfully poetic
interpretation. Yeah. Bit.
>> Yep. And here's James G, the guy, the
apostle, right? Overseeing the line,
right? Fascinating. I have been close
friends with Brian Simmons for over 30
years, translator of the the press
passion translation. So
it's it's all so connected and it's sad
in the same time right that they all
endorsed it.
>> Uh Michael W. Smith also endorsed it by
the way.
>> James
>> Yeah. He even read uh on his videos uh
out of the passion translation.
>> Wow.
>> I have a video of it but I I I couldn't
stick it in here. Uh he is uh high up in
in in the whole thing. He's seen him
with Bill Haymon again. Uh you see him
with Mike Pickle, the guy that abused,
you know, kids.
>> Uh here you see all the those uh in um
it looks all great, right? All graduated
from what?
>> The Whitner Institute. Really?
>> No accredited institution.
>> That's the school that was all about
cleavage, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Wow.
>> Uh here's you with Chayan again. So, uh
you know, it's all their own Instagram
and and here they're at the White House,
right? So, they're very close to the
White House. We're getting closer and
closer to to politics, I guess.
>> In a minute, but here the belonging
they're here you see that they are the
pastor appreciation. So, it's their p
his pastor, but they he's overseeing
them, right? So, it's kind of weird. M
>> Donfinto, another
guy. Here's the Bonhov again, George and
Bonhov. So, Bill Johnson.
Uh, yeah. So, anyway, that's that. And
this is his website here. Here, uh,
James Gold's website. Here you see God
encounters. Uh, this is the 2019 word of
the Lord. Every year they have a word of
the Lord.
>> And you see all the names here. my here
chair. She's the chairman now, right?
So, she took over from u uh from uh
Wagner, Peter Wagner. Uh Bill Haymon, we
saw him. Stacy Campbell, Sharon Stone
from Europe. Um Will Ford, Harry
Jackson. I mean, all these names.
>> This isn't Sharon Stone, the actress,
right?
>> No, no, no. It's another song here.
Darlene Czech, what does she has in
common with the new Apostolic
Reformation? Well, she's from Hillsong,
right? And now she falls under the uh
under uh David Balstri who is an apostle
in the movement in Australia. But uh
moreover
uh she is has her her own church now. Um
and again hanging out with all the false
teachers. Uh these are these are from
arc churches.
And this is C3 churches. So you see all
the connections with different
denominations.
This is Brian Johnson from Bethl.
Uh Joel Oin, Steven Ferdick and uh Mr.
at Lakewood, right at Joel Osin's church
with Kurt Franklin, I believe.
>> Yeah.
>> And and uh and another worship leader uh
Brian Houston and not Brian Houston. Uh
uh uh Hton uh Joe. No, what's his name?
>> I don't know.
>> Israel Israel Hilton. He's a a worship
leader. Estrol Hutton.
>> Wow.
>> Uh
I believe David Meyer is either
the husband of Joyce Meyer or the son,
but I think the husband. She's praising
Eugene Peterson, the contemplative
pastor, the book.
who also wrote Ojene Peterson wrote also
rewrote the Bible, right? Uh he wrote
the the message
>> returning to the art of spiritual. Okay.
So he wrote the message Bible.
>> Yep.
>> As above so below.
>> Yeah. I was going to say the one where
in the Lord's prayer it says as above so
below which is an occult saying.
>> Yep. And uh obviously uh she is also um
and I'm looking for
where is it? Here she's connected with
the passage that uh we went to to the
blogging again. So here uh oh
>> oopsy the passion translation.
>> All I did is uh looking looking at the
crime scene and I just dotted
everything. Right. So
>> wow
>> I connect the dots here.
>> Yep.
Yeah, it's like I I get it that
sometimes the Bible can be hard to read
and stuff, but why aren't we trying
really hard to understand it? Like
busting out the Strong's concordance or
something. I'm never going to
read a Bible that has someone else's
commentary or their own paraphrase
because you don't know their agenda. You
don't know their
their own preconceived ideas are now
being put into the Bible. So now you
can't study the scripture like we're
supposed to. Line upon line, precept
upon precept here, a little there, a
little by the mouth of two or three
witnesses. Now you're getting one mouth
and you're comparing their mindset
upon itself. You can't, you know, the
Bible has
um there's 66 books written by over 40
authors. And that's what makes it such a
miraculous book because these are people
from all walks of life from fishermen to
kings spread over the world over uh
1,200
years or 1,500 years that the Bible is
compiled together from different books
and different parts of the world all put
into this book. And it's so perfectly
tight-knit that nobody can debunk it.
It's the prophecies are coming true.
Stuff from the Old Testament lines up
perfectly with the New Testament. But
when you have one person writing their
version, you're not getting that. You're
not able to put the Bible to the test.
Now you're just hearing some man's
opinion or worse, their agenda.
>> Yep. Yep. This is Lance Wall. Uh this
guy is basically the as I mentioned in
the beginning he uh
>> basically rephrased the seven spheres
and made it the seven mountain mandate.
Uh he created the mandate of it. He
wrote a book with Bill Johnson about it.
>> Uh and he's 7 m underground that is his
organization
um seven mountain right seven mountain
university.
uh he is part of the international
coalition of apostolic leaders IAL that
I showed uh last time and it's uh on the
list later um and then he is also part
of usal is the US regional um guys and
then he's part with BETHL
uh and also ACPE so uh the what we just
saw with Cindy Jacobs he he's also
teaching at the Wagner Leadership
Institute right that we saw
>> he's a member mber of the Oak initiative
chat by Rick Joiner which we go into
later in later in a minute. Um I mean
it's it's bizarre. He is he's doing so
much so much thing so much stuff. He's
on uh here this guy is connected with uh
um u
what's his name? Um
>> it's the Victory Channel. And this is
connected to uh the Victory Channel is
from uh Kenneth Copeland.
>> Oh yeah. So there you see the connection
again with the with the prosperity
gospel. Um Hank Kunaman uh I believe it
is uh also in that movement.
Uh let's see he's uh Robert Henderson.
He's uh all about uh the courts the
courtroom of heaven. He's storming the
courtroom of heaven all the time and
>> kind of Yeah. The courts of heaven.
>> Yeah.
>> Unleashing the courts of heaven.
Unbelievable. Wow.
>> See here, uh I mean all the connections
here it's I can go on here but uh I
don't want to uh bore too many people
but let's roll the next video and
explain a little bit more what what Mr.
uh Wallnau is video five.
>> Okay,
>> a little more about Mr. Mr. Wall now.
>> There we go.
>> The root of this teaching is ultimately
demonic. It's not something that's oh we
have some differences but Lance Wallnau
as Joe has already articulated to you
guys. These guys think that they as they
as he said will tie up the kingdom here
into a nice little bow and then hand it
back to Jesus. We're so glad we were
able to do this for you there king. But
the fact is is they believe some very
strange things. And as Lance Wallnau,
who's already we talked about writing
the book alongside Bill Johnson from
Bethl, invading Babylon, here is him
talking about how believers and
Christians and the church actually are
the ones that determine his words, not
mine, when the Lord returns.
>> And so, but the one who endures to the
end will be saved. And this gospel of
the kingdom will be preached in the
entire world, the whole world. It's a
testimony to the nations. And then the
end come. The end doesn't come when
Islam rises. The end doesn't come when
China rises. The end doesn't come when
the Antichrist rises. The end comes when
the church rises and the gospel of the
kingdom is preached. It's the church
that determines when the end comes, not
the devil.
>> And grant to us, Lord, strength to be
able to carve our way into the places
where the gates of hell are located. I
pray for a breaking down of gates of
media, breaking down of gates of
government till there's a baptism of
truth in the minds of Americans and this
veil is torn. I pray for a net formed by
apostles, prophets, evangelists,
pastors, teachers in every mountain and
media and academia.
>> And I I wanted to play that clip not
only because Joe, I I have to ask you,
is it the church who determines when
Jesus come back? I'm going to ask you
that. But you see the fervor with which
he he prays and it's very strange
praying like that the way he does. But
this fervor by which he prays for these
seven mountains and to know these
pamphlets are being hand handed out at
more mainstay churches that people would
know in Texas and so forth. But then to
hear those words that the church
determines
the end, I I just I find that to be
absolutely pretty weird.
>> Yeah. And the context there is when the
church rises up and it's not, you know,
the antichrist rises up, he doesn't
determine it. Well, we read Revelation
13 uh verse 5. Uh let me see this
chapter 13:5. Listen to what it says. It
says there was given to him that is the
antichrist a mouth speaking arrogant
words and blasphemies and authority to
act for 42 months was given to him.
Okay. He opened his mouth and blaspheies
against God to blasphe his name and his
tabernacle and those who dwell in
heaven. Verse seven. And it was given to
him to make war with the saints.
It doesn't say and the saints overcame
him and overtook the seven mountains. Is
that what it says?
>> And to overcome them. It's given him to
over uh to make war with the saints to
overcome them and authority over every
tribe and people and tongue and nation
was given to him. So the church doesn't
rise up and take over the earth and and
you know bring the kingdom in. The
church actually uh suffers at the hands
of the antichrist and
>> man good point.
>> Yeah.
Amazing uh how how he states that that
we are the ones that uh that you know
that decide that's arrogance man like we
decide Jesus comes back. It's kind of
the same thing that Brian Simmons said,
right? Like Brian Simmons was also kind
of saying like uh he he comes back
because he's even worse saying that that
we're the incarnation of Christ. Uh
>> yeah,
>> it's but Lance I mean Lance is you know
he thinks that we can usher in the usher
in Christ's uh return which is
>> and that we're going to basically set up
Christ's kingdom here on earth like
we're going to make it perfect and
>> and basically
>> nice bow on it and hand it over to
Christ, right? Look.
>> Yeah. Presenting a perfect kingdom to
Christ. We can't do it. We live in a
fallen world. There's no way we can ever
make it. Anything that we build is going
to become rust and moth food. I mean,
that's what the Bible says. Store up not
your treasures here on earth. What do
you do with verses like that?
>> Do not store up your treasures here on
earth, but treasures in heaven.
Man, it's like these people don't read
the Bible. Or maybe they're reading a
different version.
>> True, true, true. Uh, actually, if you
go to the next video. Oh,
>> yeah. Yep.
go ahead and play it or you want to set
it up or
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, you can you can play it.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Let's backtrack our way out of
this little rabbit trail and focus our
attention on the guest speaker who is
who is who I should say who came to
Fresh Start Church and spoke January
16th of this year, 2022. And here is
Pastor Paul struggling to introduce him.
So, we were talking and we were talking
about what what do we call him when we
introduce you?
It's like, is he apostle? Is he a
prophet?
>> I don't know. Now, I want you to take
note of the hypnotic organ sounds in the
background.
>> Anyway, we're just honored to have him
and that he would come and be here with
us at Fresh Start this morning. Would
you put your hand?
>> Sorry, I didn't mean to do that.
>> Together, please. And welcome Dr. Lance
Wall.
>> Lance Wall. Well, if you haven't figured
it out yet, this video is dripping with
the signature elements of the most
dangerous movement in evangelicalism
today, the New Apostolic Reformation.
And if you have any doubts about that,
simply go to Ical, the International
Coalition of Apostolic Leaders. Now,
here is a list of of member nations. And
as you can see, there's quite a few of
them. And under the about tab, we find
this in the ICAL uh website. The second
apostolic age began roughly in 2001.
Now, I have absolutely no idea how they
were able to come to that conclusion.
They go on heralding the most radical
change in the way churches done since
the Protestant Reformation. This new
apostolic reformation embraces the
largest segment of non-atholic
Christianity worldwide and is the
fastest growing churches of the
apostolic movement embrace the only
Christian mega block growing faster than
Islam. Now if you go to the biblical
views tab you will find this under the
subheading of the kingdom of God.
They write, "We affirm a that the
believer, I'm sorry, that the Bible
reveals God's intentions for the growth
of his kingdom in all nations of the
earth during this present age through
the proclamation and obedient
application of his stated will in
scripture." and B that his intention
includes the increasing manifestation of
his rule over all individuals, voluntary
associations, families, the church, the
state, and all fears, spheres I should
say, of human activity. some of which
are and he's going to they're going to
uh list just a couple for us. Law,
government, economics, business,
occupations, education, sports,
medicine, science, technology, arts, and
media. Now, there are a few more, but
that's nothing less than what's called
the seven mountain mandate that is
championed by the new apostolic
reformation and specifically Lance Wall
now, as will become clear.
>> What? That that's the first time I heard
sports. Maybe I just missed it before,
but
>> yeah, it's fall it falls under
entertainment, right? Entertainment is
kind of sports and
>> music and film music. Uh, yeah.
>> And I I I'm trying to figure out where
which scripture which chapter and verse
does it say that Christianity is to take
over the government and sports and all
that stuff entertainment. I mean,
>> so if you roll the next clip, he's
actually going to explain a little bit
more about the mountains.
>> Okay.
>> Taught our people. Jesus was given
nations for his inheritance.
Now that comes from Psalm 2:8 and is
loosely used by Jesus in John's
apocalyptic vision where Jesus tells the
church in Thotyra. He says, "The one who
overcomes and the one who keeps my deeds
until the end, I will give him authority
over the nations." But just what is
meant by the nations?
You know what? You know what does go on
into eternity? This is weird. Nations
continue.
>> But wait a minute. Wait a minute. At the
second coming of Jesus, at the end of
this present age, nations as sovereign
states will be no more. I mean, we're
told that in Revelation 19 where it
tells us in symbolic language, mind you,
that when Jesus returns in glory, the
birds of the air will eat the flesh of
unbelieving kings and commanders and
mighty men, of horses and riders, of
everyone, slave and free, small and
great. You see, that pretty much covers
everybody that makes up a nation. There
are seven areas where the gates of hell
I'm going to just put these crowns up
here. Seven areas where the gates of
hell seek to set up their camps to
control the minds of multitudes to keep
them deceived and to take over nations.
See, now where have we heard that
before? Well, just go back to the quote
that I cited at the beginning of this
video from Ical, the International
Coalition of Apostolic Leaders.
government. I'd have to tell you about
about the danger of that. Media,
entertainment, the arts, entertainment,
and then uh what do we have here? 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 I have an extra mountain here
for the Mormons. There we go.
You see, this is Lance's thing. This is
what he does. He's the pied piper of the
seven mountain mandate, which is nothing
more than warmed over dominion theology.
>> Wow. Why did he throw it in? This is for
the Mormons. What was that about?
>> It's just uh that's his humor, I guess.
I don't know.
>> I mean, are they saying that Mormons are
just as much believers as the rest?
>> We we come to that later.
>> There is another another video later
where somebody else like Rick Joiner is
saying something similar. So they really
believe that Christians are just going
to take over everything from arts to
legal to school education, everything.
>> Yep. Yep.
And so that really ties in with the
whole Project 2025 thing, which we've
talked about on this show before, how
um Project 2025 wants the next
Republican leader or Trump to be able to
have all authority to write any law
about anything, including religion. And
we know according to prophecy that there
is coming a one world religion enforced
by law. And for some reason, the the
church is so asleep that they think that
that has to be some kind of like
I don't know like satanic religion or
something. Oh, when the satanic religion
is forced by law, that's the antichrist
system. They don't realize that it's
going to look like Christianity. It's
going to look so close to the truth.
That's why it's deceptive. That's why
it's deception because it's a lot of
truth, a little bit of error.
Now,
what who was the first one that wanted
control? And and the Bible speaks of
like the first beast. What who was that?
That was that was the Vatican, right?
>> Rome. Yeah.
>> Weren't Weren't they the ones that
wanted to Christianize the world,
>> right?
>> That's that's the that basically this is
nothing else.
>> Yeah. And so when you read Revelation,
>> it it clearly says that the first beast
is Rome. And then it talks about this
second beast that rose among it rose
around the same time that the first
beast was falling. That's none other
than America. There's no other nation
that was rising at that time. That's a
superpower like it is today. And it says
that the second beast will build an
image to the first beast, which means
it's going to create a system that's a
mirror image of the first beast, Rome.
America's doing that right now as we
speak, even on a physical level where
you go to Washington DC and you see the
the capital is a dome with a fallus, an
obelisk in the front. That's exactly
what Vatican Rome looks like. Identical.
You got the dome and the fallus. This is
all fertility stuff. You got the
pregnant belly, the fallus,
>> and so America literally is becoming the
mirror image of the beast Rome. And it's
happening right now. We're setting up
the
>> Huh?
>> Now you got an American pope, too.
>> An American pope. I mean, dude, it's
nuts, ain't it? And even Trump saying
that he's the pope, whether it's tongue
and cheek or whatever.
>> I know.
>> It's It's all prophecy, man. It's all
it's it's Rome and America uniting
together because it says that the the
second beast will cause which is America
the second beast America will cause all
to worship the first beast
and and that's Rome. So, if we come back
to a time, which it sounds like it's
trying to be set up right now, to a time
where religion,
quote unquote Christianized religion is
enforced by law. That is the image of
the beast system. That's the antichrist
power right there. And how many
Christians are going to fall for it?
Tons.
It sounds
>> I mean, the Bible clear that even if if
it were possible the elect, right? So,
>> right,
>> it's got to be such a deception.
>> Yeah. Wow, man.
>> So, the next guy is Jay on. If you uh
show my screen.
So,
>> wait, your screen or
>> my my my screen.
>> Your screen.
>> Yep. So, this is Jay. We saw him before.
Uh and he is basically one of the big
guys right now. He took over uh Harvest
International Ministries uh from um or
he has no he is from Harvest
International Ministry. He is now the
chancellor of Wagner University. That's
uh that's what what he took over and
Cindy Jacobs took over the ACPE from
Peter Wagner. So everybody took over
some of Peter Wagner's things. Um but
yeah, he's from Harvest International
Ministries. And if you see here uh I
mean the reformers pledge with all and
that's not the the reformers from the
past right it's the new reformation. So
here you see him with Harry Jackson.
U here you see Sydney Jacobs, right? So
they're all it's uh it's all together.
Here you see together with Lance Wall
now. We just saw Lance Wall, right?
>> So it's it's all connected. Everything
is is all aligned with one another. You
see again with the lens wall now
um Lou Angle
uh from Descent and this this is guy
skywatch
Harry Jackson
again with Cindy Jacobs. So the it's
it's on and on here you see him with CP
Wagner with Col Sanders right?
>> Yeah
>> manager.
So, and he's clearly saying like spirit,
my spiritual father, right, and mentor.
>> Wow.
>> So, I I captured everything, man. I
captured all the here. The seven
mountains of influence,
>> dude. That picture right there.
>> Yeah. The church and the state, right?
>> Church and state unite. That's crazy. It
says there's no separation of church and
state. God's kingdom involves all the
seven mountains of influence.
>> Wow.
>> That's what they want.
That's what they want. There's the other
guy again.
So anyway, uh this is Mark Corona is
other also and God TV, right? So all
these Christian TV stations, TBN, God
TV, uh Day Star, they're all part of the
whole thing. Charisma Magazine, same
thing.
>> Here's uh you know, Eric Mataxas
>> also part of also part of it.
Um, here's Michael Brown.
>> Yeah, I do know.
>> And he's he's called an apostle as well.
And he didn't say, "Oh, no, no, no, no.
I'm not." He didn't say that.
>> And you see the
You're going to see him in in one of the
videos next. Um, but they're all
connected. That's how how it works here.
Lou Angle, all these people.
>> Wow.
>> You're all all the same people. James G.
Uh here the global heaven on earth
summit right again. So they want to
bring heaven to earth.
>> Yeah.
>> So here's the Maldonado again and Jayon.
So it's all connected here. Anyway, so
and this is Lauren Cunningham. Remember
from from the first video
>> that
>> we did about reformation. He's one of
the guy that had the vision of the seven
seven mountains. Wow.
>> He was from uh from Youth with a
Mission.
>> So,
yeah. Anyway, uh let's Oh, this Oh, this
is close to home because I I know this
guy. He owns a big camping in in the
Netherlands. Uh and he is an apostle and
here with apostles from Holland.
>> These were the pastors of my church in
the Netherlands. One of the five they
uh they had a five-fold ministry kind of
pastors and these were pastors of the
church that I went to. I know them. My
parents know them.
>> Dick and Arlene uh Westerov.
>> So I told you in my in the last video
that I was very close
>> in every church that I went to. Uh Berea
was the church and the Brians, right?
They so they the and they called Berea
and they they were not really Bereans.
>> Yeah.
>> As you can see.
>> So that was the church that I've been
born and raised in. Right. So Assemblies
of God. Um but anyway, so the this
church then I went to the US and we come
to that later. Uh that's the ark
churches and they're also apostles and
we see that in in a moment. And then uh
you know I went to the uh to a church
that was governed by uh uh um Kenneth
Copeland
>> who was also in and then I went to
Nashville to to a church where uh Lou
Angle uh James go was overseeing that
church right the belonging. So my entire
life I had different flavors
>> but all led to the same new apostolic
reformation. Yep.
>> That's insane,
>> dude. This is scary to see it all come
together like this.
>> Yeah, this is his website. Uh Jan, you
see here Wesley and Stacy Campbell
again. Uh those are the apostolic
council office here. Brian and Candace
Simmons from the Passion Translation.
>> Wow.
>> They fall right under. And these people
fall under Ton as well as the
international apostles.
It almost makes me like, not that I have
time to do this because I any moment I
have time to read, I want to read God's
word, but it almost makes me want to
read the the passion version and see
what is their agenda because there's
such a push for this version and towards
the youth and everything like these are
the ones they're saying we're going to
change the world and and you need to
read this version, the one that was
given by another spirit.
I know.
>> It's like the new world new world order
translation.
>> Yeah, it is. It is. If you go to the
next video, uh number eight,
>> is it the one right with this?
>> This one. This one. And we talked about
church and state, right? Let's let's I
don't know if it's this one or the next
one, but let's I think it's this one.
Let's roll the tape.
I was at the 20-y year anniversary of
Toronto and um during that time Toronto
was a great outpouring of the Holy
Spirit for those of you who don't know
and saw millions of people come into the
kingdom. Chay knows all about it. It
affected many moves of God, the Revival
Alliance, IHOP, different places like
that.
>> Chay, we know that um Lance Wall now
especially in this last couple of
decades has been highlighting um the
seven mountains of influence. Jay, can
you uh list just for our viewers that
might have never heard of the seven
mountains of of of influence, can you
list them for us?
>> Yeah. Again, it's it begins with I think
the religion mountain or the church
mountain.
>> Uh the family mountain because God
established the family in the garden
first. Then we have what we call
business mountain which is huge because
talk about everything from uh your your
store, your uh business to corporations
in America and around the world. Then we
have what's the government mountain
maybe the most important mountain. Wow.
>> And and the idea of separation of church
and state, this platonic mentality is
really of the devil. We're to be
involved in every area including
politics and um the uh the media
mountain, the uh arts and entertainment
mountain. These seven mountains are
absolutely critical.
>> Now can you give us some theology for
the seven mountains?
>> Yeah, absolutely. Because from the very
beginning in Genesis chapter 1, he told
uh Adam and Eve, I want you to be
fruitful, multiply, fill the earth
because I'm I don't want heaven on earth
as a small geographic location. I want
my glory to cover the earth as waters
cover the sea.
>> And then he says subdue the enemy, which
is interesting because part of our
humanity, the real humanity made in the
image and likeness of God is take
authority over evil.
>> Yeah. And that's part of transformation
is how are we dealing with the issue of
of evil in society.
>> Yeah. All the injustice issues that are
out there.
>> Exactly. Racism in society.
>> Yeah. We cannot be blind to it. We
cannot just ignore it.
>> But then it says take dominion or rule
with him. And so we're co- lababors with
him.
>> So quick question. Was there uh in
Genesis uh prefall
was there evil?
>> No, not at all. So how can he say that
we have to take dominion over evil,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> I mean take dominion over the enemy.
Which who which enemy? There was no
enemy at that point. So
>> I guess Satan,
>> what is he talking about? Yeah. Well,
the sin came later, right? But God said
take dominion over over over all the
earth.
>> Uh that was basically uh had nothing to
do with enemy. Had to do with the you
know the fish and the and the and the
plants. As I said in the beginning,
that's what what what was talking about
was not talking about enemies,
>> right? And I even think that
>> saying taking dominion over the animals
and stuff wasn't any kind of like
forceful power. It's more like tending.
You know, we're supposed to be the
gardeners.
>> Take care of it.
>> Yeah. Take care of it.
>> Exactly. And it might be a a bad
translation. I'm not saying, you know,
even though I believe like the King
James version is a really good
translation, there's still you're
changing Hebrew, Greek, Hebrew, and
Aramaic into English words. We don't
always have the right English words.
Sometimes when the Bible says forever,
it doesn't mean like what we think
forever means eternity. It says that
Jonah was in the belly of a whale
forever, but then it says 3 days later,
he was spit out. So for that word eon
means a completion
an amount of time until completion and
yet it was translated forever and to us
forever means eternity. So there are
some nuances like that and so maybe when
it says dominion maybe that's not like
the best translation in the English word
because we think dominion like
empowering or over overpowering.
Well, uh, he might have he might have
read the Passion translation.
>> Yeah, that's probably what he's reading.
Also, for anybody that's like maybe this
is kind of new to them when it when he
was saying like separation of church and
state, that's of the devil. That's like
Satan's motto. No, it's not. Separation
of church and state, you know, atheists
love to use that by saying like you
can't have a nativity scene or you can't
have a cross in public and all this type
of stuff. They they try to say
separation of church and state, but
that's not what separation of church and
state was formed for. That was about
keeping the government out of religion
so that we can have freedom of religion.
Freedom to worship whoever we want,
however we want without the law saying
no, you must worship this way or be
killed or or to be say you don't have
you don't have a freedom to worship
whoever you want to. That's what this
that's what makes made this country so
great was that we fled the persecution
of the papacy who was saying if you
don't bow to the pope you will be
torched to death or if you even even
other things like um if you try to
translate the Bible out of Latin into
your native tongue you'll be killed so
the founders of this country were
fleeing the persecution of that and
founded this country not on Christianity
That's a lie, too. This country is not
found on Christianity, but it's founded
on freedom of religion. To be able to
worship the way you want to without the
threat of death or being punished by
death.
>> Yeah. So, if you go to the next video,
uh so what they're also very much into
is declaring and you know, prayer um
declaring and uh and uh decreeing. And
let's let's watch this video.
Cheayon
has been a heretic for a long time. Uh
he considers himself and calls himself
an apostle. Uh like a living apostle
here today. And when it comes to Chon,
he was involved and I would say because
we did this a long time ago, Joe, where
we showed quite clearly in our Bethl
series when we did the live Q&A, we
showed the very weird is the best way I
could describe it. weird um you know I
don't know some sort of it looked like
witchcraft to me it was they they think
they're doing some Lord of the Rings
>> sorcerer staff man
>> yeah using a sorcerer staff and they
prophesied that they were ending racism
in the church and uh just from that we
know they're false prophets
>> but before we show the clip I mean it is
definitely witchcraft because you're
taking Gandoff's you know which is it's
actually silly it's embarrassing uh you
know to be called Christianity uh And
it's also a denial of the power of the
Holy Spirit that you have to rely on the
power of magic from Gandalf who who you
know what does the Bible say in
Deuteronomy 18 9 through12 when thou art
come in a land which the Lord thy God
shall give thee thou shalt not learn to
practice the abominations of those
nations shall not be found among you
anyone who practices magic reads omens
you know a wizard and so forth sorcerers
you know contacts the dead necromancers
all that it's because of this the Lord
says I put them out of land I'll put you
out too talking to the Jews warning them
not to practice the abominations these
because these wizards were contacting
the demonic entities, familiar spirits
that claim to be dead people often. And
uh here we have at Bethl, they're
practicing, they're taking Gandalf's
supposed from Lord of the Rings. I guess
that makes wizardry acceptable all of a
sudden,
>> his staff and banishing the spirit of
racism, which by the way, it didn't
work, folks. You know, just there's so
many uh ridiculous things that go along
with this. But this is and the the
serious thing here that we need to focus
on.
>> Bethl is supposed to be claiming to be
part of revival that's with power of the
Holy Spirit. This is absolute denial of
a reliance on the power of the Holy
Spirit when you're looking at magic. And
it shows you that they're not truly
relying on the true Holy Spirit of God
by and large.
>> Yeah. And and when you look at at this,
you it's it's very awkward. And we're
going to play it right here because I
want to I want them to do the justice
here because they do quite enough uh
than us talking about it. But just
notice some of the awkwardness between
these quote unquote prophets as well as
you watch this clip
dedicating your home yourself as a
ecclesia
inviting the presence of Jesus into your
home.
>> You know, we're going to do some binding
and loosening. You know, one of the
things that I've learned in the last
maybe around 10 years that apostles have
authority to make decrees and
declaration.
>> Now, everybody understands if you know
Lord of the Rings, everybody understands
what's in my hand.
Everybody understands what's in my hand.
>> And during this process, I've been
asking God, show me the act. Show me the
act. But the Lord told me I needed to
repent for the participation I had with
the racist spirit in America.
We are going to lift
the staff
>> and we will command this spirit not only
to leave
>> but he shall not pass.
>> Now if you heard what Apostle Savosa
said, he said that you need to oil your
door. So I encourage you if you haven't
done this in the proper order, you must
put oil in your door and then go in
front and repeat this act with us. So as
an apostolic team with the authority
that God's given to us, we decree and
declare that racism will end. It's over
in the ecclesia from this night forward
in Jesus mighty name. Let's lift it up
and bang it.
>> Hallelujah. Come on, give him a praise
over. Repeat with us. Thou shall not
pass.
>> No more.
>> Amen.
>> I'm sorry. We did it twice. We need one
more.
>> One more. We need you to agree with us.
>> Okay.
>> On the count of three. On three.
>> Shout with us. 1 2 3.
>> Thou shalt not pass. the name of Jesus
Christ.
>> You know, when you throw out the name of
Jesus Christ as if it's an abracadabra
at the end of a spell, it it's not what
the authority of Christ actually being
in our prayer life is all about. And you
see them and in that clip, you hear
Shayon talking about you to hear you
hear him talking and you also see they
were very particular about this whole
situation, anoint your doors and so
forth. So it I mean does that not
resemble some a spell?
>> No, absolutely Chad and that's a good
point. I was thinking the same thing
that the order and it happened to be you
know you have to anoint your door.
Where's that in scripture that you have
to anoint your door with oil?
>> Uh let me see where the church is told
to do that and we have to be careful
that of that ourselves as Christians
where we start doing things that aren't
in scripture because we just think
there's some kind of supernatural power
attributed to it as believers. So you
have to anoint you have to hit it not
once but twice. And they're all like
laughing after the first time. Oh, it's
worked. And the second time. And then
the lady's like, "No, it has to happen
three times."
>> And then guess what? You have to agree
with us. So all these things have to
happen, including everybody agreeing
with them. Otherwise, you leave one
thing out, the spell is not going to
work. Now, if someone wants to say,
"Well, this is a prayer of the Lord."
Oh, really? using Gandalf's wizard's
staff, pounding it three times, which is
which is has the whole connotation of
magic. And and those, by the way, when
you're using a wizard staff and you're
using a magical way in the occult, what
you're doing is commanding demonic
entities. And what blows me away is this
is a church which claims to be involved
in spiritual warfare, which is just, you
know, you know, open sesame to the
demonic world through their practices.
And unfortunately and tragically and
sadly, Satan, because they're seducing
spirits and doctors of demons, a lot of
their music reaches like the tentacles
of a demonic octopus into all kinds of
churches and and people are drawn uh to
this kind of theology which is
unbiblical and it's setting people up
for a demonic invasion. there. It's
actually what's heartbreaking is I've
read a lot of uh statements from Bill
Johnson and his entourage, his wife and
others where they're basically trying to
use a lot of new age stuff and that's an
example of using witchcraft and they're
trying to baptize it and basically we've
talked about you know the necromancy and
and laying on uh you know tombstones and
stuff to get power from the dead and so
forth. We did that recently when we were
dealing with uh Bill Johnson's wife and
so forth. So you have a lot of occult
activity and the scriptures when we see
this antichrist moving the end there's
the worship of demons which is a big
part of it. People don't repent
Revelation 9 18- 21 they don't repent of
their worship of demons and what's
happening a lot of people don't even
realize that they're opening themselves
up to demons through various practice
>> man that's disgusting
um
>> have you ever heard of the knock of
three?
>> No I haven't.
Free Freemasonry uh uses that in oult.
It's the knock of three to open the
portal.
>> Interesting.
>> Yeah.
>> Wow.
I was just thinking, you know, there's
so many people that just think
as long as the name of Jesus Christ is
said in a church that it can't be an
evil church.
They they think that if you're a
Christian, you can't be possessed. Or
that if you are a church that's using
the name of Jesus, there's no way it
could be a false church because because
you say the name of Jesus. But yet,
there's scriptures that say, you know,
many are going to say in that day when
when Christ returns, many are going to
say, Lord, Lord, didn't we prophesy in
your name? Didn't we do many great
wonders in your name? and and all this
stuff. And he says, "Depart from me. I
never knew you, you workers of
lawlessness."
They they did not have the spirit of
obedience. They didn't have the spirit
of
uh yeah, obedience, like obeying God,
but the spirit of lawlessness like this,
like we're going to baptize
Christianity, we're going to do this
ritual on stage. I mean, that's
lawlessness.
This is this is straight up condemned in
the Bible
because God doesn't want us messing
around with demons.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Uh so the tentacles of Mr. uh Chon
goes deeper also into the the Calvary
Chapel. Uh I mentioned it before. Um if
you go to the next video,
that's also a good fight. Great. Um,
>> yeah, this is a good breakdown. I'm glad
they're saying this stuff because I know
they're basically Baptists and I didn't
know where they stood on some of this
stuff, but I'm really glad to hear them
saying some of this.
>> Yeah.
>> But to see this switch from some of the
bigger names in Calvary and to see them
going down this rabbit trail of
politicizing the gospel and that's been
something that has been really, really
dangerous. When you see what you have to
interlock with, what you have to
compromise, that dirty, filthy, nasty
word, compromise. One of the worst
things that can happen to a pastor is
compromise. And teaming up with false
teachers, teaming up with people like
Shayon, maybe even having Shayon come
and speak to start your event and to
talk and give a word regarding who you
are to them. And in fact, you're going
to hear right now from Shayon who his
hero was from the Freedom Sunday event
from last year.
>> Also want to thank Pastor Jack Hips. I
love you. You're my hero. Thank you so
much.
>> Now, I play that because of a number of
reasons. One, we know cuz we've seen the
clip of Jan Markell at Jackib's church
warning him talking not warning him but
talking with him about N talking with
him about the seven mountain men
>> and about Bethl
>> and how bad it is and he agrees. He even
reads a letter from somebody uh where he
I'm not sure if it's that or another
time during that little conference thing
condemning uh the the the the demonic
type stuff that's going on there. So
he's not ignorant of it and yet he has
I've heard him speak openly about these
things and he has Shayon coming on for
Freedom Sunday alongside Tony Perkins.
And then in this next clip and this is
why it's important we've talked about u
these roads leading to worse and worse
compromise. And that's what we're going
to get into uh because you can see Jack
Hibbs hugging it up with Shayon. It
wasn't just a video sent in. He also had
some hugging going on where they got
together, but also he with in that event
on Freedom Sunday with that he helped
run with Tony Perkins. He had someone
come up and pray by the name of General
Boyin. And I want you guys to see and
hear him right next to him. And we're
going to start with a word of prayer.
And I'm going to ask General Jerry Boyin
to come and lead us in our prayer.
General Boyin is the executive vice
president of the Family Research Council
after serving 36 and a2 years in the
United States Army. He's a true American
hero.
Thank you all. Thank you very much.
Thank you all.
Join me in prayer. Now Joe, that's an
event that Jack threw that Jack was a
part of Family Research Council. He
brings up, he not only is with Tony
Perkins, there's plenty of problems
there, but but he brings up uh they they
bring up, we'll say together, and he's
excited right next to him, General
Boyin. Now, General Boyin himself is a
member of Knights of Malta,
>> can be seen pictured right next to Rick
Joiner,
>> who's also Knights of Malta,
>> who's also Knights of Malta.
>> Catholic uh group.
>> Yeah. A Catholic order. And I got to ask
you, and this is this is the important
thing because your pastor, we've thrown
events, we've done conferences, all
these sorts of things. If somebody said
to you, "Hey, we're we're trying to
fight against tyranny." And you know
what? Uh we we were trying to make sure
we could meet during COVID and Shayon,
they fought the government and and won
and they won some money back. And so he
wants to say hi and tell you how much of
a big fan he is. And then we're going to
have General Boyin, a guy from Knights
of Malta, come and and pray right
before. Can we do that at your church?
What would your be your answer?
>> Uh it's kind of a kind of oxymoron in a
way. You know, you're dealing with the
irony the Knights of Malta and a
Catholic order. Uh and you know, Rick
Joiner and these guys, you're talking
about uh tyranny. I mean, what was the
Protestant Reformation over? Over
religious tyranny and leaving the Roman
Catholic Church because of their false
gospel. Yeah.
>> And because of repression uh because of
their greed uh and how many Christians
have been put to death by Rome uh and so
forth. And uh there's so much irony in
all of this. It just blows me away.
>> Wow. That was good, man. They they
brought us some really good points that
I'm glad that they are aware of.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. Absolutely. Absolutely, man. Uh,
as as I said, Knights of Malta, and I
have on my on my um screen, I've got
Rick Joiner here. That's the the guy
that we talked about. And we saw him a
few times passing by, right? Uh people
hugging up with him on on the
>> on the photos and uh and that kind of
stuff. And in the Wikipedia, he's
mentioned as Neo Apostolic Reformation
Apostle.
and he's uh I mean he's part of morning
he's the pastor of Morning Star senior
pastor of Morning Star Fellowship Church
>> uh the founder of uh Morning Star
Ministries and then um here he's a
member of the Knights of Malta as you
can see I'm the of course I'm I put it
in there but here you see him with Cindy
Jacobs right so the it's all
>> all together
>> here with James go
>> Yep. Y uh he was with Lens Wall now.
[Music]
>> So he's with uh the guy from Dayar,
right? So uh it's it's Sedra the guy
>> biggest names in Christianity like
biggest channels and everything.
So here you see uh in the next page here
you see uh the final quest and this is
about the grays and the blues and uh
basically uh is what he's saying is is
that uh a war is coming.
>> Um and it's very interesting. We we'll
get to that in a moment.
Um but yeah, he's basically saying there
are uh Christians that have the Holy
Spirit, right? And there are Christians
that don't. And they have to be
eliminated.
>> What?
Wow.
>> Yeah. So, it's going to be a war
uh against fundamental Christians. And
>> is he talking about like a spiritual war
or a physical war or what?
>> Yeah. No, no, no physical war.
>> Wow.
>> Uh and we'll we'll we'll have to um uh
get first. Let's roll the the uh number
14.
>> Okay.
>> Uh let me see here. Uh 14 first.
No, not that one. The next one. We go
back to this one later.
>> Okay.
>> Uh no, next one. No, next one.
>> Nope. Next one. No, next one.
>> Sorry.
>> I guess I could look at the title here.
Okay, this one's 14.
>> Yep. Perfect.
>> All right, let's do it.
>> We're in time for war. We need to
recognize that. We need to mobilize.
We need to get ready. Uh I'm talking to
law enforcement.
>> What
>> talking to people? U one of the things I
saw in a dream I had related to our
civil war was that
militias would pop up like mushrooms
>> and it was God.
>> These were good militias. We need to
recognize the times need.
If God's people don't become a part of
the militia movements,
uh the good militia, the bad people will
take them over.
>> And we have so often abdicated territory
to the enemy because we didn't want to
get into something. Well, Jesus himself
said, "There's going to be a time when
you need to sell your coat and buy a
sword." Now that physical weapon of
their day and we're in that time here we
need to realize that what I also saw in
my dream was the Lord had seated our
country
with veterans from the Iraq war,
Afghanistan, all these wars we've been
in recently.
Many who know how to fight in urban
warfare
are going to be a part of the leadership
of these militias and help us in what's
about to unfold in our own country.
And these are going to be patriots. M
>> these are going to be those who are
going to they know what the tyranny of
Marxism is and they've seen its evidence
and the cruelty of some other ideologies
and all that is out there and know but
they are going to be able to help give
leadership to these militias that are
popping up and this was a God thing. He
prepared us for this.
>> Wow, man.
>> Isn't that militant? Uh it sound
militant just exactly like the guy from
Dutch sheets with the dots right
>> exactly what he's one of those apostles
>> with his ministries that is
>> and he was in military in so
>> wonder what he means when he's saying
he's been talking to law enforcement and
stuff like are they backing him
>> uh no I mean at the end of the day we
all know what's going to happen right
it's going to
religious war is going to happen and uh
>> yeah,
>> he's gonna stand on the side of the
government so we know on what side he's
standing on.
>> Wow, man. Yeah, dude. It It's so
obvious.
>> It's so obvious that prophecy is coming
true right now and that it is right
around the corner where religion will be
enforced by law. as I see so many quote
unquote natural disasters happening. You
know, we just had that camp mystic thing
that flooded out and 27 people died or
something and and it's like everyone
wants to rally around and and say,
"Yeah, we stand with them and these
Christian people." And I that's a that's
a good thing. I I get it. I just know
that Satan is orchestrating everything.
That's why I said quote unquote natural
disasters.
Satan already knows his agenda. He knows
his plan. He knows prophetically what's
going to happen. And it's all about
bringing about this false Christian
spirit
that's militant and enforced by law. And
what did we see this past Easter time?
We saw like all these celebrities
saying, "Oh, celebrate Lint with me this
year." And you got Gwen Stefani and I
can't remember Marky Mark and all these
other people with the ashes on their
forehead talking about celebrating Lent.
Lint isn't even a Christian holiday. I
mean, I grew up Christian all my life. I
never heard of any Christians
celebrating Lent, but all of a sudden
you have celebrities pushing to keep
this Roman holiday.
And um and as as da as disasters
increase more and more, as chaos ensues,
the world is going to be like screaming
out for some kind of order. We need a
savior. We need order. Whatever that
looks like, we need something. And
that's when Satan's going to come on
scenes. A supernatural being doing lying
signs and wonders, miracle working
demons. And it says that in the latter
days, many will fall from the faith,
giving heed to seducing spirits and
doctrines of demons. Like I said, I
don't think this is right out in your
face like the occult. I don't think that
all the world is joining into, you know,
standing on pentagrams and casting
spells. They're joining
a a religion that looks like it's all
about love and unity and acceptance and
tolerance. and peace because it says
when it says peace and safety, sudden
destruction will come upon them. So, we
have to be like
we have to really be on guard because
this is going to be so deceptive. I'm
I'm talking I believe that God has given
you, me, my wife the spirit of
discernment. Has given us a gift for
discernment, seeing things in movies and
and what's going on in the political
world and everything. And that's nothing
of myself. That's no glory to me. That's
all God. I was the blindest Christian
ever, man. When I first became a
Christian, I was attacking Christians
for saying that Harry Potter was pushing
witchcraft. I was like, "It's a kids
book, man. Like, get over it." And now
God has knocked those blinders off. All
praise be to him. It's only because of
him that I even have eyes to see and
ears to hear. But even I am terrified of
the deception that's coming because I
know
it's going to be something that we've
never faced before. We've never faced a
supernatural being doing miracles and we
have to stand firm and say, "No, this is
demonic."
I mean, that's crazy to even think
about.
>> Yeah.
So, um, if you roll the next tape.
>> Okay.
>> It's also Rick Joiner.
>> This is the one.
>> Yep.
>> I've been having prophetic dreams. I did
as I shared on the video last week. Uh I
got caught up into heaven for eight
hours.
It was just awesome.
The end of the dream,
the very end of the dream, I ended up on
Main Street down here, our Main Street.
And I'm standing there. I'm in heaven
and I'm on Main Street. And the Lord
said, "You've got to bring this here."
>> What? You've got to bring this here.
>> We're going to have heaven on earth.
>> We're gonna have heaven on earth right
here. The first place in scripture that
it's even mentioned that God had a
house. We've talked about this a lot. It
was where Jacob laid down, had his
dream, and he saw the angels of God
ascending into heaven and then
descending.
which to me I believe this is the most
basic revelation of what the house of
God is supposed to be the place of
access to heaven where God's messengers
are sending into the heavenly realm and
bringing back to the earth evidence of
heaven's reality demonstrating heaven's
authority over every condition on the
earth
>> which is what Jesus did when he preached
the kingdom
he demonstrated its authority over any
condition on the earth, storms,
sicknesses, demonic power, anything,
kingdom of heaven has authority over
that.
>> We're going to walk in that.
>> Amen.
>> Okay, that's our goal. And for most
Christians who are, I think virtually
most Christians are today familiar with
the teaching that Lance Wall now has
spread all over the world the world on
the seven mountain strategy. The seven
mountains being the major power centers
of influence in the world and
infiltrating these centers of influence
[Music]
because as we train others to engage
these mountains
as we ourselves cross over like I've had
to do in the government mountain educ I
go to universities I end up in the
Hollywood uh places and gated big
communities. I end up I go into these
places and I say to myself, what am I
doing here? But you see, that's the
whole point. The kingdoms is plural.
Notice the word kingdoms. He shows them
all the camp. One thing if you said the
kingdom singular because then I could
figure, oh, it's the kingdom of the
devil versus the kingdom of God. But
it's kingdoms. That makes total
confusement.
>> Now, I do believe Mormonism is a
mixture. I mean, many of them are solid
believers in Jesus Christ as their
atonement.
>> Yes. Um, but there's other stuff in
there, you know. Let's don't go into
that.
>> Sure.
>> Jehovah's Witnesses, in my opinion, have
a lot of stuff mixed in. Watch and see
these people groups become the most
responsive to the Lord.
>> Whoa.
>> In these times,
>> whoa.
>> Coming in droves, all of them together.
Uh,
>> the Mormons I have met have done more to
feed people. They have literally
factories of canning and giving and all.
So, you know, I I I I have to say that I
know they're living out what's written
in the pages of the Bible. We may all
not agree on everything.
>> I told you what's coming.
>> Yeah. I mean, hey, there's a lot of
atheists that are feeding the poor.
There's a lot of newagers that are doing
a lot of great things when it comes to
humanitarian work, and that's a good
thing, but it doesn't get you into the
kingdom.
>> Doesn't save them.
>> Yeah.
>> Nope. doesn't see
>> truth. We must worship him coming that
they would say it, right? I told you
that this was coming that somebody would
say it out loud. But that's exactly what
they think.
>> Wow, man.
This is this is like so eye opening. I
hope everybody else is seeing the same
stuff. I mean, you're really doing a a
great job of laying it all out point by
point and just yeah, connecting the
dots. And this has been going on for
some of these clips are a little older
and it's just showing how long they've
been laying the groundwork. So now we're
at project 2025, you know.
>> Yep. And the next next video is uh is
also Rick uh Joiner uh and uh also
talking about the war again.
So, you may have seen where this rant,
my rant has been covered on, I think
Newsweek and MSN,
uh, other outlets
because they think I'm inciting people
to a civil war.
>> I've been warn warning about the coming
civil war actually since 1987.
You know, that's a long time. That's 33
years. uh
>> 33.
>> But in, you know, after I had that dream
in 2018
when I was shown in the dream, it's now
inevitable
and it's time to prepare for it. But
anyway, you read those articles and
those media outlets, they twist things
pretty bad. But it's free advertising.
Cause more people to watch this and
other things we put out.
>> Wow.
a civil war. So, yes, literal war,
right? As I mentioned.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> So,
so if you go back to my screen.
>> Okay.
>> And then so mention I have like 20
minutes left. So,
>> yeah. Yeah. I
>> This is like this such a huge topic.
>> The owl. See the owl here?
>> The owl. Oh, no.
>> I can't see that. owl
or
>> is it at the top of your screen?
>> Oh, the logo. But that's fine. It's
fine. Here, this one. It's not an owl.
It's an eagle.
>> An eagle.
>> There's there's symbolic meaning behind
all that.
>> Yeah,
>> the eagle we use it in America, but it
was also used in the Nazis and the
Vatican, all that.
>> Yeah, exactly. Oh, man. It's Yeah. So,
here you have um let's see here. Here's
again uh the the Knights of Malta,
right? And last time I also mentioned
Paul Kaine and uh and here you see the
combin also Adolf Hitler. I mean he was
uh approached by people from uh from um
let me go here. Paul Kane last time I
spoke about Paul Kane. Oh I can't okay
for free. What?
Okay
skip.
Okay. So, uh Paul Kaine was one of the
the
uh
how do you call that? The uh Kansas City
prophets, right? Where
>> uh Mike Pickle and and and the IHOP, the
International House of Prayer came out
of. Uh Paul Kane was one of those early
prophets that basically was a a
drunkard. And I don't know if he was
also um
uh homosexual or not or if that was only
with the other guy, but yeah. Oh yeah,
here homosexuality and alcoholism.
>> So uh that's where you know
where the fruit of all this uh and he
was also knights of Malta the uh
together with uh with Mr. Um this guy
was Rick Rick Joiner and you openly on
Morning Star his own website right who
are the Knights of Malta right so it's
on his own own website
>> and then you see this one here
>> why did I join the Knights of Malta so
>> oh no way dude
>> he's just openly steing it on his own
website man so here some pictures online
>> oh wow Wow, dude.
>> You can find it if you Google it. You
can find it.
>> But this stuff's right on Morning Star.
>> No, this is on on on Yahoo uh on images
search.
>> But this is Morning Star website. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> But uh but then the images are just if
you can Google them or on Yahoo or
whatever.
>> Wow.
>> Here is another one.
>> And another one here. This is the guy
Jerry Borin.
And this is again the picture that we
just saw. So uh that's crazy.
>> That is crazy.
>> Crazy. Crazy. Now if you go back to uh
let's see here to
>> one of the videos we
>> number Yeah. video and then number
10 if not mistaken.
Shan.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Is it No,
no, no, no. 11
>> 11
>> 11.
>> Okay.
>> So, here you hear Chon explain uh that
uh apostles are restored, but at the
same time that they have been on planet
earth for a long time. So, watch the
video. It's very interesting.
>> You are to bring heaven to earth through
the spirit of God within you. is
Zechariah 4.
>> What? I'm supposed to be bringing heaven
to earth
>> barely get out of bed in the morning?
How am I supposed to bring heaven with
me?
>> Let me back this up just a few seconds.
>> This is amazing. You are to bring heaven
to earth through the spirit of God
within you. It's Zechariah 4:6. It's not
by your might. It's not by your power,
but by my spirit, says the Lord. And
>> yeah, not by might, not by power, but my
spirit says Lord does not mean that I
have to bring heaven to earth,
>> right?
>> Taken to bring heaven on earth. But the
second thing that he says is that the
church is founded upon apostles and
prophets, Christ Jesus being the
cornerstone.
>> Yeah. No, no, he didn't say founded
upon. It's built on the foundation
of the apostles and prophets. If you
don't lay a foundation twice,
>> you you lay it once. And if your
foundation like
goes kaput, then your your your the
whole structure is going to come
collapsing down. Just saying.
>> It's amazing the interpretation of that.
A lot of people who don't believe in
apostles and prophets today will say,
well, the prophets is referring to the
Old Testament, the Bible, and apostles
referring to the New Testament.
When you think about it, think about
Paul's an apostle. He begins Romans 1:1
says, "Paul, a bondervant of Jesus
Christ called."
>> Yeah. You You didn't say the word
foundation.
Isn't it weird that he just like omitted
that word?
>> He said founded upon. No, no, no. The
church is built on the foundation of the
apostles and prophets. See? Yeah. See,
just let just read the text in context
and sit there and go, "Oh, yeah. I get
it." Uhhuh.
>> To be apostle, he knows what an apostle
is.
and he's traveling with a prophet named
Silas at this point. Began with
Barnabas.
>> Now, you're going to note here, it
sounds like he's arguing that the church
needs apostles ongoing.
>> We'll get to that in a second, but I
want you to note that. I mean, this
sounds like it's an argument for ongoing
apostles. And he's going to go somewhere
to try to prove that, which is going to
give you the heeie-jeebies if you think
about it. But uh let's let's uh not get
too far ahead of ourselves, shall we?
>> And then later when Barnabas and Paul
had their parting of the ways, he picked
Solace, another prophet. And then he
goes and says and elaborates this in
Ephesians 4:1 that when Jesus ascended
after he descended because he had to
first descend to take the spoils of
>> Okay, so now he's conflating this now
with Ephesians 4:11, we'll get there in
a minute, but notice he's made the jump
and watch what he does here. And it's
important that uh you know your pastors
know Greek. And I'll explain that in a
minute because it's going to be very
helpful to take a look at the Greek
because he's going to put an emphasis on
a word that actually doesn't appear in
the Greek. Uhhuh. Yeah. I'm just saying.
But watch what he does.
>> Or destroy the principalities and powers
taking their authority.
He ascended and he gave gifts. Mhm.
>> to the body.
>> Yeah,
>> that's you. He gave some to be apostles,
some to be prophets.
>> Now, notice what the word he's
emphasizing there. Some.
>> He gave some to be apostles, some to be
prophets. Now, I'm going to back this
up. I want you to hear his thought in
context. And then we'll take a look at
the Greek on this.
To the body. That's you. He gave some to
be apostles, some to be prophets, some
to be evangelists, some to be pastors
and teachers to the equipping of the
saints for the work of ministry until we
come to the fullness and this the full
stature of Jesus Christ until we become
a mature man. How many know we're not
there yet? We're not mature. We're not
full yet of the fullness of Christ. And
we haven't come.
>> So notice we're we're not full yet. We
haven't matured to this point yet.
Therefore, his argument ergo is we need
we need apostles ongoing
>> into the kind of unity God wants us.
Until then, we are always going to need
apostles, prophets, evangelists,
pastors, teachers. So,
>> no, no, what he said until then, we're
always going to need, let me back this
up. Listen again, because this is vital.
>> How many know we're not there yet? We're
not mature. We're not full yet of the
fullness of Christ. And we haven't come
into the kind of unity God wants us.
Until then, we are always going to need
apostles, prophets, evangelists,
pastors, teachers. So, the con
>> Now, this is where we're going to do a
little bit of work in the Greek. And
we're going to take a look at Shayon's
brand new, brand spanking, hot off the
press, new book about modernday
apostles. We'll even take a look at
>> what Bill Johnson has to say about it.
Mhm. But don't tell Dr. Michael Brown.
Anyway, so Ephesians chapter 4. Uh, it
would help if I actually typed in the
address here. Ephesians chapter 4 verse
11 is the one in question and uh let me
pull this up to you know to be kind of
concurrent and and so we're going to
look at the Greek. I'm going to read
this from the roo katos adoken and he
gave tous tous is the definite article
you know so it's the and it's plural
here it's a plural accusative and then
men here you could say means on the one
hand uh and so when you give a list of
things often times in Greek men will be
the first thing in the list and then the
next parts of the list will have will
have the uh uh the particle de and that
means and so And he gave kai outas he
adoken gave uh the apostles men you can
say on the one hand t prophetas and
prophets t yuan galistas uh this is the
evangelist Tuesday pouyos shepherds and
kai dasculus and and the teachersh
uh for the uh Qatar tissu the equipping
of the hagioin the the saints uh in into
the work of ministry. Yeah, that that's
kind of how that works. So we're going
to note here when we just walk through
the Greek words kayato adoken he gave
tous the men you can say on the one hand
apostles
to and prophets and
evangelists and shepherds and teachers.
It doesn't say
some. M
>> in fact the ESV does a really good job
of pulling this across almost word for
word and the ESV which is right here in
the middle and he gave the apostles the
prophets the evangelists the shepherds
and the teachersh
>> and so to equip the saints for the work
of ministry for the building up of the
body of Christ. Now a little bit of a
note here Peter is still teaching the
church today. So is Paul.
So is John.
So is Matthew.
>> Yeah.
>> How are they doing so? Through the
living active word of God that they
wrote.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Yeah.
>> They're still teaching us today. So now
Shayon makes a point that oh well you
know that we we in order to equip the
saints we need apostles ongoing. He's b
this is an argument for this is this has
had to keep going. Now a little bit of a
note here you talk to people in the N
even Shon and they'll note that um you
know uh apostles have only recently been
restored. Whoa. Dude, that was a really
good point to end on because
he made some really solid points that we
don't need new apostles. We don't need
new translations. We don't need new
prophets. Everything we need is right
there in the living word of God. If you
want to hear God's voice, open the
pages. I heard somebody else say, "If
>> you want to hear God If you want to hear
God's voice audible, read it out loud."
I love that.
>> Read it out loud. Exactly. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, dude, that guy killed it. Going
when you go to the original Greek, it
says that he gave
>> the apostles
definitive.
>> Yep. Very solid, man. And and that's
what they try to do, you know. They try
to here and there they try to twist
scripture. They read the scripture.
Yeah. But not complete, right? They
twist it a little bit
>> to to and and and every time they say I
uh I believe that it says this. It's
what Rick Joiner said. That's what uh
Tayon says. says, "Well, all the guys
said say uh I believe that this." No.
What does the Bible say,
>> right?
>> What does it really literally says say?
>> So, it's interesting.
>> That is. So,
we're obviously going to have to come
back and do more. You have another
presentation.
>> Plenty more.
>> Well, we're not finished. We're not
finished with this one. So, we have
>> we build we'll build on this one the
next time because we've got more. Um,
it's it's crazy.
>> In the meantime,
>> yeah, you guys, if you haven't checked
out other videos that we've done with
Minnow, go back and look at those. I'll
I'll put some links in the description
and the, you know, the little title
cards, but go back and watch the N
um the deception that's coming, how it
all started. You really should watch
that one before you watch this one. But
I guess as long as you're getting the
information and whenever you can come
back on again, I'm excited to hear what
more information you have because this
is just I mean this is already just so
eye opening, so shocking to see what
these people are saying right out of
their own mouths, right on their
websites, where things are shifting in
our climate today, and our culture
today.
I see it, man. I see this project 2025
is coming this year. I' I've been saying
it for months that I believe 2025 is
like the beginning of the end. Like this
is a huge paradigm shift towards
prophetically
the end towards the beast system. And so
we talk about it all the time. This is
not time to be playing church. This is
not time to be one foot in the church,
one foot in the world. It's time to get
serious, man, about our relationship
with Christ. Getting in God's word,
being prayed up, get closer to God than
ever before. Pray, read his word, ask
for his wisdom, his guidance in
everything we do, every step of every
day. Get the garbage out of our homes
that is inviting the enemy in that's
giving him authority over us. And to
spread the gospel, man, use this time
wisely. We need to get all our family
and friends to see this truth right
here.
>> Correct. Correct. Yeah, man.
>> So, if people want to check out, you
have a website,
>> nconnections.com.
I'm going to pull that up so people can
see. Um,
>> that's what I use basically.
And, um, nconnections.com. And uh so we
wanted to end on uh uh basically on the
the mooneyies. That's why you see on the
thumbnail the mooney. So we'll have to
change that I guess.
>> Yeah.
>> For next time. Uh so we can use that for
next time because that's what what will
be incorporated in the next presentation
then.
>> Uh but uh but yeah uh this is purely the
NEOIC reformation and u the link also to
the Knights of Malta, right? To the
Vatican and the Knights of Malta.
Yeah, fabulous website with a lot of
great information, man. Thank you so
much for coming on again and bringing us
your wealth of wisdom and it's I know
it's been eye opening for me. So, it's
probably just as eye opening for others
out there. There's some people that have
just hearing this stuff for the first
time. So, we really appreciate it, man.
And I look forward to seeing what you
got next time, man. Cuz I believe it's
going to with this Mooney's thing, it's
pretty pretty crazy.
Yeah, there's a lot more crazy stuff
coming.
>> Yeah. Well, thank you so much, man. If
you guys Huh.
>> No, I said all right. Thank you so much
for having me on, man.
>> Definitely, man. Always a pleasure and
look forward to having you on next time.
If you guys appreciate this video,
please give it a thumbs up. It really
helps it get out into the algorithm so
that more people can hear this truth and
not fall for the coming deception. And
if you would like to support this
ministry financially, you can do so by
going to candidtruth.org. We got Cash
App, Vinmozel, PayPal. We also got
t-shirts on our website. If you click on
um the store and the shop, you'll get to
see that we have a lot of cool shirts
and hoodies and mugs and all that kind
of stuff. And we get like $5 profit on
those things. And we can't do this
without you guys. Um this is our
full-time ministry. We want to bring the
truth to you as often as possible. every
week, multiple times a week, and we
can't do it without your love, your
help, your support, and your prayers.
So, share this video with all your
family and friends. Give it a thumbs up.
If you're new, click subscribe so you
don't miss another video. And we'll see
you next time on Candid Truth.